[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
what's going on lords mic check mic
check talk to me six later what's up
pat yo what's up jiu jitsu what's up
sean zoo what's going on
crazy greek dude what's going on man
talk to me let me know if my levels is
good
let me know if y'all hear me talk to me
we got a lot of sleepy lords i don't
know where the
rest of the lords are a little sleepy
pong saw what's up let me know if y'all
can hear me
in the chat sounds good all right thank
you thank you sexy i appreciate you
appreciate you yeah we're gonna get uh
we're gonna get dutch in here in a
minute
gandalf i like the name i like the name
gandalf happy lord's day salute
king is coming king is coming with theme
music so we gonna have to uh mute him
when he comes in so we don't get that
copyright strike
flemish what's up i saw you earlier i'll
check that dm i didn't forget you
what's going on attic is in the bushes i
don't know where attic's at
all right so can you guys bump the audio
up a smidge it gets louder well you want
me to bump it up
they said i was too loud last week i'll
bump it up a little bit just a little
bit
it's a little bit
slight bump up
let me know what's going on man oh man
so we're gonna get dutch up in here
let's see what's going on what's
[Music]
what's going on bro appreciate you all
right so i'm gonna get dodging here
we're gonna wait for the king wait for
solve
you know what i'm saying you know all
that good stuff
yo i see you you're ready for this for
the before to get messy i see what you
do
doing crazy big dude i see yourself what
gets five ray traces
uh we might talk about it we might talk
about it water shots what's up
all right so i'm gonna be back in a few
minutes y'all i'm gonna get dutch up in
here
and hopefully someone could find lord
addict i'll talk you out of it
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i might check right quick
i'm telling you
welcome to the world man thanks a little
brother put the crust up you know what
i'm saying put the horns up in there
you know rest up for your brother
exactly put the
joint up right quick we got something
wrong addict is in the bushes we don't
know where to get
let me find out what's going on he's
partying with
fema last night
[Laughter]
yeah we're gonna get it today yo did you
did you see ufc cuz i watched ufc too
yeah oh we gonna get it
we're gonna get it too yeah all right
we're gonna give it a couple more
minutes and hopefully the young wolf we
can get him from under the road
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi this is lord sovereign from the iron
lord podcast
as you guys may recall a few months back
king david otw announced an
amazing giveaway for the xbox series x
well i'm proud to announce that the iron
lords podcast will once again be giving
away
another console at the end of this year
and that console will be a playstation
5.
you heard correctly so how do you get in
on this amazing giveaway
let me explain if you're already a
member of the realm
you're good to go if you support us
either on patreon
or youtube you already have a ballot to
win this amazing console
and if you support us on both platforms
you have two ballots to win this amazing
console
as you also have two ballots to win an
xbox series x
so if you're not a member of the realm
what are you waiting for
head on over to patreon.com go to the
ironlord's podcast patreon page
become a member of the realm to get your
chance to win a playstation 5.
you can also join us on youtube slash
iron lord podcast
become a member of the realm and you
will also have a ballot to win
a playstation 5 console and if you want
to support us on both
platforms you'll have two ballots for
each system
to win either a playstation 5 console or
of course as king david said
and xbox series x this is an amazing
opportunity
that the iron lords podcasts are so
happy to bring to our community because
you guys give so much back to
us so again if you're not a member of
the realm yet
what are you waiting for go out join the
realm of either patreon
or youtube and until next time i'll see
you at the round table
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right like check mike check and
we are live welcome to the iron lords
podcast
and the lords of gaming.net episode
number 180
and it's another glorious sunday we're
back at the round table on the lord's
day
i'm very excited about our special guest
and we've got the playstation 5 ui
reveal
900p series s games
sony's last console and day one next-gen
games to discuss
so we're gonna get right into it i wanna
introduce a lord who is not only one of
our rising content creators within the
gaming community
but has already built an outstanding
reputation for custom consoles and
controllers
all done with outstanding craftsmanship
introducing the creator of the wondering
dutch youtube and twitch channels
and the host of the midweek mix-up
podcast
the gaming viking himself
and the lord who brings that afc a jack
smoke
in fifa 21
live from newcastle and making his debut
into the realm of the lord mommy
lord wandering dutch how you doing sir
i'm doing good i'm doing good i love the
intro
we gotta bring you in the realm right
brother how you doing man
i'm doing good i'm doing good just just
getting the place that looking sorted so
it's nice and tidy again nice and sorted
in the in the room
not yeah i see you looking nice out
there you got the nice setup going on
man
little remodeling action going on a
little remodeling getting it getting it
ready
no no no so besides slaying people you
know and fighting all that good stuff
uh what else have you been playing yeah
i saw the stream what else have you been
getting a chance to play
uh i've been playing quite a bit of road
company lately that's uh
quite an easy you want to jump in and
jump in and play i mentioned uh you've
seen on twitter trying to go onto
destiny 2 and get my ass handed yeah
uh program for you sir november 18th
don't worry don't worry there you go
they actually it's a point of contention
that they're gonna revise for for new
life players so
we got you you know i'll be joining you
on december 8th though in the 60 frames
that's what
[Music]
yeah i thought so too until budgie put
the announcement in all next-gen
is coming up what you call it uh 60
frames on december 8th they they pushing
the patch back
but all the systems even the series has
everybody and they do a field of view
sliders like pc
which is which is huge so that will be
out day one though
that'll be out the 10th i believe to
feel the fov no what i've heard
from what i heard it's uh together we
gotta wait we gotta wait so
it is what it is
after a night of fantastic combat mm-hmm
i went to bed how you know when you go
to bed with a smile on your face like oh
it was
a good night yes i got to call 4 30 in
the morning like oh we need you
so i'm almost literally just walking
through the door right now so
i'm in the bushes but i'm here amen
you're worse than me
yeah well for certain aspects of my job
i
am on 24 hour call so i
you know it's to be expected but it's
still heartbreaking when it comes
actually when the phone actually does
ring you just look at it like
oh hell no oh god that's okay
sir without with all the work you still
do you get a chance to play anything
this weekend nothing that you're in the
bush is completely this week no haiti
not even hades i guess um so that's it
man i still have
don't worry i ain't played either yeah
yeah could you wait for it to come up
i can't wait till you actually play it
cause you're gonna be like oh my god no
you know i see it all the time it looks
beautiful
and you know i respect your your your
rogue uh like uh
gameplay stuff i respect you sir and i
definitely can't wait to feel dominance
maximus aurelius spencer
brings it to gamepad you know what it is
those games like that like dead cells
and and hades
you you get increasingly better uh yeah
you become stronger and
go along right so it helps you a little
bit there's certain things that run
to run you that you lose but certain
things overall you're getting stronger
a game like spelunky which i wanted i
want to play
uh definitely part two um
right it's more like a straight up rogue
like
it has instances where you are getting
somewhat better
but more often than not it's just it's
like that mind game
right the um that that um is on game
pass right now that
they keep throwing me down in a little
dungeons that little mind game that that
game is a roguelike too
it's good but it's not like the action
uh pure action all out like you know
neon abyss that
that's my crap yeah yeah the abyss is
crazy too i haven't played that yet but
i've heard fantastic things about it so
so that's it no gaming this week i'm i'm
fraud
[Laughter]
it is it is what it is
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka
the access gamer oh the prophet
of xbox king of the statues who defends
nothing less than that premium
experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir
you know i'm doing fantastic but hold on
one second
[Music]
oh
let me tell you something man this iron
man is the uh
masterpiece line of xm studios this is
one of my holy grails
is absolutely stunning
when y'all get the chance to see this
joint um i'm gonna debut
the uh the nine on this you're gonna see
it in 5k
if your tv don't display it don't worry
about it
you're gonna get the 4k look at the 4k
downgrade downgrade
we're going to under clock and we're
going to remind us out of the boost you
know
we're going to use
but um uh first first first first first
time
first let's let's give a shout out let's
talk about the ufc sob
let's just get into that ufc did you see
the ufc sir i saw
i only got to see the uh the ortega uh
korean zombie fight
okay okay let's just let's just go there
because all right the other fights is
but let's get to the ortega uh korean
zombie
because when i'm watching it when he
came out with the no here
uh-huh what that was there because i was
like no when i saw that i said oh my man
streamlined like a missile he like a
bullet he's going for the heart
he is out here for that bang bang
pause he would he he went in for the
whole
fight and nothing but the fight and he
re-branded the hell out of himself
yeah oh shout out we gotta give a shout
out uh we want to get a big cloud
we got us real quick hear me once again
we have
we have big cloud with the five dollar
super chat it's the lord's day smash
that like button thank goodness
playstation what's going on for sure so
when they when it was getting in the mix
you know what what took it aback it was
like usually ortega
is you know balls to the wall all out
and
a little less refined than he was
yesterday he showed
poise he showed uh direction
he showed that he was coherent at all
times
because that's spinning back elbow that
he caught the korean zombie with and he
didn't even hit him flush
he hit him with the back of his bicep
and
yo the korean zombie was like what the
hell
you know what it is it comes down to
when a fighter takes a loss like he took
to holloway yeah like it's it's a it's a
moment in their career where it's either
okay
they get changed for the worse at that
point or they learn from that and they
come back even stronger
and i think what you said is is exactly
what happened with him he came back and
he knew
that he needed to be more measured like
he needed he you can be aggressive but
you need to learn how to stay in the
pocket and move
in and out and not stand yeah and use
and use your face to block punches like
you can't do that
um so i at first when i saw him with his
head shaved i was like okay this
this means he's he's focused or this
means he's off his rockers one of the
two
one of them so um to see him that focus
i was very happy because again he this
is a guy that was skyrocketing to the
top
and then when he met with bless like
that
it kind of got derailed completely um
and he realized that he was not
in that class yet so he didn't go back
to the drawing board so to see this is
great because korean zombies no no
pushover i don't know yeah he
he absolutely isn't i saw the levels of
his movement
um he was going high low mid he was
definitely leg checking him
um zombie couldn't get off at all shout
out to um
jimmy crook though the boy the
australian cat the um
like heavyweight man big right hand
slayed that boy he coming you're coming
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah definitely
definitely what's up let's get this next
super chat and then we can go
into the the i'll get it vendetta with
super chat king barry over there trying
to hide with just his nose and beer
belly poking out
plotting your murder where is where is
mario all right so
mario is in the display
yo and if you notice i had to block him
with the xm box
because mario was down here oh so that's
the keeper because he's loose
yeah mario mario will be on some
annabelle stuff
him in there
[Music]
now what it is what i'm saying fake is
because david devin hayden has a belt
okay so they're really trying to act
like he's oh god
but yeah uh vasily lomachenko uh
the matrix versus uh female lopez
uh the takeover right
yeah yo i was going to come into that
today oh and teo femo has the ibf belt
and
lomachenko had all the other belts like
wbo bo
wba uh wbc franchise belt
and um the thing with it with that is
they was building up lomachenko to be
the second coming of god
right they was building him up to be the
most incredible
fighter since muhammad ali if you're
listening to bob arum
and lomachenko showed flashes of that
brilliance and he is but that's proper
matchmaking
he got into a fight yesterday with the
young
younger stronger uh
fighter a a lion that didn't have an o
in his wreck
undefeated okay undefeated and
that boy did not want that o to go so
first six rounds
he was controlling lomo like you've
never seen before body head movement
movement movement
but lomo felt that he was going to take
him to the deep rounds
by the eighth round lomo started to come
on
and then you've seen the brilliance of
lomachenko
and the kid just didn't bend break or
fold
like he was like treyway all day like
okay okay well i
truly was supposed to be continued
[Laughter]
so the boy was putting in putting in the
work and lomachenko was trying to
pressure him you saw him trying to drown
him
but the kid just kept coming up for air
here he would turn him here spin him
he'd throw the uppercut
and he heard lomachenko uh plenty of
times in this fight something i didn't
think that was gonna happen
um oh first i have to give a shout out
to uh raquino
oh yeah he looked at him yeah me and him
was going back and forth chatting back
and forth
and we was uh like yo i hope they don't
rob oh boy
12th round came in that 12th round
he showed me he had balls of steel
because lomachenko met him in the middle
of that
ring and tried to go for broke and then
it fought him off and beat him back up
against that rope
and uh definitely if it was 13 or 14
rounds here to probably like
lumberjack wow so this is coming of age
stuff this is just the boy
put his line in the sand and was like no
i'm here
so my prediction yesterday combat talk
was supposed to uh make his triumphant
return
uh i had some technical difficulties and
i had to uh shoot out and
take care of some stuff but it was my
whole prediction of the fight was going
to be
lomo by split decision because you got
to respect these old dogs these
they're both olympians and you know uh
loma is a two-time olympic gold medalist
while uh i think uh 10 females are silva
or gold i don't i have to double check
but both olympians you got to take it
from the champ
yeah and the i was like i don't know if
the boy is
ready to take it from the champ well he
took it from the champ so they gave it
to him too
yes no no no they he took it he took it
ain't getting man you know how boxing
sometimes well this is this is this is
the thing that's interesting about this
right
it's like in boxing especially when
you're at the statue of alomo
you can you can sort of dictate who you
fight you can dictate who you fight and
and you can make fights that make sense
for you right uh
as great as floyd mayweather is like he
was able to dictate who
he fought and he was able to fight guys
he was able to see
weaknesses in guys that and exploit
things and guys that maybe some people
couldn't
so he knew when to fight them he knew it
was an appropriate time for him he was
money mayweather not pretty boy pretty
much
when he became money made he became more
of a businessman he's like okay let's
let's figure out how to do this
so the fact that you see the a 23 year
old kid no matter what his record is
get a shot against lomo yeah um
boxing isn't sort of boxing isn't built
that way like you got to build yourself
up
you can have you know 20 wins on your on
yeah
back alley precisely for the fact that
this kid got the shot
and did not squander it that's what's up
and now now again now and he was talking
about it at the end of the fight like i
he literally said i drew the line in the
sand now all the other kids the up and
coming ones that's it we're ready to
take over everything
so um it remains to be seen if if his
brethren coming up
aren't going to get those same shots
right but uh
he he i didn't like when it came to the
the number scoring right i thought i
thought the fight was closer
indicated
[Music]
[Music]
lomo won like some part of the round
lopez came in and run the other half of
the round
so it was whatever they was looking for
and in this coveted state right now
i just don't have no distractions
there's no crowds around bothering them
so you know you're not going to be uh
swayed by the crowd like oh
none of that they've seen what they're
saying they're going by what they're
saying yeah this is what's up
they're gonna hit us with the time soon
so
that's yeah is you may you may miss the
crowds right you may miss that that
atmosphere but to tell you the truth
this is as pure as it gets
boxing ufc this is this is we're in the
gym in the gym
yeah you know um first i got to say uh
uh my prayers go out to guys from uh
game on daily
uh his grandmother passed away i was
supposed to be
on this show on saturday but uh due to
the tragedy
of course yeah you know family and
everything everything
is first you know so my prayers go out
to him and his family absolutely oh my
condolences to god
yeah so what i was playing this week
so after seeing that uh um what is it uh
that uh assassin's creed um
yes i had to get my odyssey
had to finish my joint i had to play
hard so still ain't finishing it yet but
i was playing that
and neon abyss and some destiny because
you know festival of the lost no doubt
i love the haunted forest i really i
really love that aspect of it you know
go through the darkness and then like a
spooky house and
fight the ball so i love those little uh
event time events for
you know definitely so that's where i
was at playing this one that's what's up
and of course we have the gaming ninja
himself
the shinobi unlocked incognito spreading
that realness in the ramen
iop not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear yo happy
boring day sega master system y'all put
it together
for one of the goats for one of the
goats the little red and black joint you
had it you know you had it the
studios we were talking some sega talk
man so it was good to see you so salute
to that man
yo stop stop i see you fanboy with the
neis for life man i see you in there
i'll see y'all in there stop it
this is sega's day man y'all had y'all
this is sega's day man
but andy was the first to do all back
compact remember there's the z80
listen you know it was doing vr backpack
all that stuff down man
it was ahead of their generation
definitely we will get revenge for you
you already know what it is um yeah
shout out to the last word last night
man
i bought this and now we had on thai guy
travis from ign's fire team chat
so absolute man he was tremendous he was
talking that titan talk
having everybody laughing man good
episode please check that that's up on
our
shout out for him getting his name on
that banner oh yeah yeah
you listen you listen yeah you listen to
the joke absolute salute
and uh yeah for me other than that man
it's been out of worlds man i was
supposed to try to jump in the ghost uh
i know the new co-op most came in for
goshima but
boys a little tight last night so i get
to get to it but i'll get to it tonight
and um other than that just out of
worlds but i've been having so much fun
xcloud on the go as well as at home so
uh yeah that's been it for me man but
other than that let's get to the show so
now that we've gotten to what the lords
have been playing i want to focus
on lord dutch his video game system
history
his journey into console design and of
course what led him to creating the
wondering dutch youtube and twitch
channels
as well as our favorite midweek mix-up
podcast
lord dutch man let's start from the
beginning what was some of the first
video game systems you had we got you
the gaming
first one that actually got us at the
game was probably believe it or not the
pc
i used to game game with me further on
on pc all the time uh build pcs
start from the ground up uh flight sims
uh side-scrollers that's hardcore that
that's what's called man that's hardcore
right there
how old was you when you was doing how
young was you when you was doing this
about no about about eight nine years
old wow
okay and this is building pcs at a time
when it was i mean now it's where it was
dial-up connections
yeah uh after that the the other
consoles that i had
would have been the sega mega drive
uh the super nintendo the nintendo
original nintendo uh then on to
playstation one game boy game boy color
game boy advance
playstation 2 missed playstation 3
360. oga og xbox one
xbox one x xbox one s
pretty much had everything playstation 4
pro playstation 4 you name it let me
shout out some cards
you haven't mentioned did you because
you had a very wide range
any turbo graphics in there
uh not for me but extended family had
all of those oh okay extended family
in lofts and whatnot you need to wind in
the tape back we had all of those
consoles
trying to have rewind to get the game to
start again
yes speaking of turbo graphics real
quick did you guys see the
analog uh announced a new turbo graphics
uh
what nah i didn't know about that yes
they did
it's gonna be 200 bucks and it's uh fpga
complete so it's no emulation
it's straight up like it's it's it's and
it's everything
it's the the duo i mean it's it's the
the the
card reader discs wow so they're doing
that's the cd
everything yes i'm down with all that
no analog consoles are crazy yeah that's
crazy that's what's up
so let me let me back up just a second
because um again wide range of systems
tremendous history so give me some
standouts for you
like let's start with the um like the
16-bit era give me some standout games
for you
oh stand out you know you see me again
starting on pc pc was my that was my
original home
yeah um but i used to love the the
the old pointing clicks but again the
age of empires was one of my favorite
from
always one of my favorites i used to
play it again on dial-up
what was that motor speed was that motor
speed you were 33-6 it was 14-4
that was a 33-60 okay let's get it let's
get it
it's going well
it was proficient it was sufficient to
play the uh multiplayer game mode castle
blood if you all remember that
real pc so i mean being that you have
such a tremendous pc history
that what was the draw the console
decided to just because it got popular
because it seemed like you were kind of
entrenched in pc it was mainly the
the co-op multiplayer button but couch
co-op when couch co-op first came around
with the likes of
again on playstation 2 and og xbox one
when that came together especially for
halo the original hero
when that first came out i remember
standing in the pc shop for us which was
pc
world over here originally before it
turned into curries
um but having the the og xbox one on its
display stand and having halo as a demo
and i just couldn't
ever since i played that there that was
that was it that was the draw that was
the game changer right there yeah that's
what's up
get that any any lan parties or we just
kept it
kept it solo halo was slam parties yeah
halo island parties all the way
everybody put the tv over had
that's true so you you were already
advanced you were so ahead of us with
the pc space
castle was just catching up to what you
always do so you're like okay they're
just getting on
apart from the dial up drops which yes
and that's it god
somebody picked up the phone and kicked
you off your game
[Laughter]
ma get off the phone
[Laughter]
get back here to the crackling
no that's all right but no it's um again
but you're going back to og
og gameboy as well if you all remember
that with this with the cable that you
had to connect to each other
yes i remember that with game boy
advance when we were playing tony hawk
let's get it oh well were we sitting
there with the links
remember oh yeah and california game
california games
slime world that was fun
but you know what's funny like game boy
was so popular
and like what's funny remember remember
like so you had to buy like a kit there
was like a magnifying glass
that tetris was rocking it was the
greatest i don't care what nobody
says yeah man so you had the hair health
you had that game boy
okay yeah that's what's up match from
amenities trevetti's history man so just
kept
you still but you you'd be pretty much
doing everything console and pc
all the way up through wow tremendous
tremendous sir
so um yeah man after that like i know
obviously um
i'll continue before you get into your
content creator stuff but one thing that
you're known for is obviously these
these console designs these custom
controllers these amazing things
like what kind of birthed you into into
that field like what got you into that
i've always been very arty crafty myself
anyway
um but primarily for me and what really
bro
broke the camel's back should i say was
seeing some of these
high-end customized controller websites
charged
absolutely through the teeth for
something that could be done far cheaper
um i don't i'm not going to name names
because i'm not going to throw a shade
like that
there are a few um unfortunately one of
them
is american based yeah um and they like
to charge
fortunes for something that costs far
less and i'm talking
talking 150 to 200 markups wow
so when i saw that and one of them was
uh why
before the white elites came out yes
i've seen the uh order
ordered a wide elite from one of these
companies um paid i think it was double
what the elite was
costing at the time and it was just all
they'd done is just attach a
white a face plate onto the front of it
no that was it
the rest it was completely misdirected
like the on the on the website that had
panels on the back that were all white
and back the controller was white
controller arrived front faceplate was
white and that was it
wow nothing was this it was like
absolute jokers
so uh got the pulled them up on it got
the
entire website was changed that i said
all right we'll take we'll take new
photos and
not miss new photos so it's
really really that big as far as like do
do you think it's like
based on what you're saying like it was
something that you would see is very
prominent
you know in that community as far as
these companies doing it just completely
over charging and stuff like that
oh completely overcharging yeah and it
was the fact that i
the wholesalers that sell the parts that
they sell be you can because you can get
all of the vast majority of these custom
controllers you see are just parts from
china that have been made that way
anyway
so it's not something that has been
designed or handcrafted by them it's all
digital off print it onto a shell and
then put on old controller
which is fine but then it's a market up
150 200 percent and then sell it too
that's what ground my my gears
um but no specifically for that i went i
went out in a limb
um saw how much all of the wholesale
parts were
ordered an absolute boatload of
wholesale parts and then
got airbrush and started airbrushing
started doing uh getting all the elite
pots uh again
wholesale edit parts in so you could
essentially turn any control into an
xbox elite pad or a playstation leap pad
or a nintendo switch pro elite pad um
any kind of paint you can imagine
whether it be glossy or matte or
rubberized or
literally just finding out what would
work best what wouldn't work
right um trying techniques and then
getting to the bottom of it and saying
right okay well for my
all i'm going to charge here is for my
time
completely transparent with where i when
i sell so what i'll tell them i'll say
right
controllers or cost of controller unless
you have a controller you want to ship
to me first
to customize this is the wholesale cost
of all of these parts
so you decide what you want to put on
the controller and then
for my time for actually physically
customizing it by hand
then i'll charge depending on what how
the the complexity of the design
right so i only usually maximized uh
anywhere between 10 and 20 uh dollars
for my time
wow max that that that's pretty
honorable sir because um
you know as we see uh you know as far as
you know this is a big business
controllers and customization has the
popularity of that has really gone up
so salute to you because that's how i
think i first came across you on twitter
you would have these amazing
designs and i'm like who is this dude
like like he's
making all this fly stuff and i'm like
yo this is crazy so to see you
do that and just to see where your
position is about that is very rare
and it's cool to see now you've always
had that background or this is something
that you just said you know what
i'm gonna try this you know what i'm
saying because i don't like what's going
on in the industry
i've always had an art an art background
so i'm i can
draw and paint and everything like that
fine um in terms of technical ability
again that goes back to being able to
disassemble and reassemble pcs and
things on the fly so being able to
disassemble a controller was pretty easy
and then consoles again same thing
that's why again i love the
the the complexity of the ps5 shell it's
just a case of snap
off they would go ready to go um and
again the capabilities of that
is gonna be much easier for me to
customize but for me
specifically it was it was i had the
background in art anyway
but it was the the one that pushed me to
start doing it and doing it
again far into cutting it but also to
create something that was
one of a kind for every customer as
opposed to just i like this controller
make that controller
right it was more of a like bespoke you
do you tell me what you want on the
controller and how you want it and i
will make it to that way
nice that's fine i'd rather stay i'd
rather stay bespoke than just something
you can buy off the shelf
it gives a much more much more special
for the customers absolutely in person
i saw you made one for uh for patcher i
didn't get like a a
g one that was fire man pubg elite
controller yes that's right absolutely
can't wait to play that on the x oh yeah
yes yes you want to get that super chat
sir
your mute is tough there you go that's
it
there you go i forgot ladies i've had
the microwave on
um i'm ancient gamer with the five
dollar super chat uh
say something sir thank you for the for
the super chat then we have stitch with
the five dollar super chat what's the
deal with the ubisoft rumor
uh it's a ruler it's a rumor
it's funny now that might i mean with
that purchase of xenomax they got like
yourself buying everything
you can buy everyone then everybody's
cop it's two it's two
first first remember i was talking about
that ubisoft thing
um but it's it's two rumors that are
really prevalent and
are i i really think i can sink my teeth
into those two
so i don't know hopefully that stuff
means true but you'll see in game pass
look at november 10th will tell you
what's going down
[Music]
you continue dust but yeah man i love
what you're doing with that
tremendous as far as that you know as
far as the designs and stuff like that
now do we have a site so i
got a promo on you brother like you got
a site right there or they could just
hit you up directly if people want to
get their
you know controller on or consoles
design life it's just directly on on
on twitter i haven't created a site yet
i would to be fair if
if i was creating a site it would be
mainly to to showcase what i have done
and then tell them
kind of email anywhere to discuss what
you want
um because it's not again with it being
completely bespoke it's not a catalogue
of what you can choose from
right it's a case of which controller
which console and what to say
that's it tell me what you want yeah
fair enough well let's see with the
playstation 5 i can just send you my
wings
and leave my joint button inside the
living room
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
good morning lords and shout out to
dutch for joining the round oh
salute salute you know sam you gotta add
that to the building
but um let's talk about lord dutch the
content creator like how did that
transit what inspires you to get into
youtube get into twitch do streaming
create a channel like what was the
inspiration
uh actually it was uh myself and the
dutch lads we're always
again the vast majority of time when we
can we we come together
um again always on club gaming uh
getting pub g but it was always the fact
that we'd even
throughout these games anyway we always
talked about this like
gaming news and things in between
playing games um
so we thought i'm gonna i'm gonna create
a channel but it was following watching
things like the iron lords and rdx
and the way you guys do things as well
whereas it's you have fun doing it it's
not just
reading off a script news here we go
you know you know what i mean it's not
fun you keep it real
and and going through it as well it was
the the ways kind of go about doing the
show
that's something i wanted to bring
across as well it was have fun bring in
a good community bring
again like yourselves you've got a
massive community as well a very
loyal community um so it was it was to
build that community as
as well for ourselves um that enjoyed
games as a whole we can poke fun at both
xbox and playstation and nintendo
with poke fun we're never serious um the
only time we are serious when something
really does go wrong or something really
does
um go bad like again
when we were starting before xbox
dropped the whole bethesda news and
things like that
um you've seen you've seen quite a few
of us as well saying like
that this is going far too slow you
haven't shown anything
you haven't shown any games i think it's
a month before release
what he's playing at and we're all
starting to get a bit antsy another
bethesda news dropped and of course
changed to change on a time but
[Music]
yeah narratives seem to change a little
bit yeah
but we we call out we call out when
things aren't going right
and that's what we try and do but we
want to try and have fun so
again when you guys came on as well that
was uh
it was a great show had a lot of fun
there we had a lot of fun man
yo so salute to the team like because
you again you know
i love the energy you know first of all
humble that you mentioned us you know as
far as
the inspiration that it's surreal to
hear that song right like because
i feel like we still haven't been doing
it that long ourselves
you gotta read dizzy
[Laughter]
the iron delegation
dizzy you know i don't read that stuff
but that was funny
but this duchess beard is like in the
realm of like you know it's nice and
and taken care of
bearded white guys are easy to come
[Applause]
how in the world would you pick snickers
over milky way what's happening
man all right so i let this real quick
there's a chain reaction on twitter
uh shout out to the action luca cool it
was it was a couple other oh random
thoughts
i picked snickers too yeah i don't know
what the beast is
so like they go in that milk so
basically it was snickers
milky way twix and reese's pieces
and they said one of them gotta go i
like that
see that's what they like i i see i like
milky way
but i'm like yo i'm not a person that
like nuts in my my kid
boys right like i said if y'all like
nuts that's
y'all so it was a joke and it kept me
going
so everybody's coming at me like yo
milky even bill still i was in it was
like
you made the wrong move milky way should
have been out and i said look man eat
your zone if y'all like nuts you're
kidding
wait wait wait you said snickers gotta
go yes think he's gotta go
no no you're in the bushes
listen i
you get your halloween bag and somebody
threw a milky way
with you all oh i took all the milky
ways
so y'all sound like that sound like the
almond joy kind of lords
that's another one that can go in the
bushes yeah so i like it anyway enough
this is getting sidetracked
but anyway shout out to fuzzy vulva
they're being messy that's right tell
him gig
listen nah man it's the truth and he
definitely deserved this today
[Laughter]
straight in the bushes but anyway moving
along did we catch the super chat we all
caught up
yeah we'll cut up yo black ronin said
team nuts i'm stupid with you yo you
stupid yeah
moving along
and i love you brother that's not the
goal that's not again
that's not to go to right
hijacked dutch segment anyway
continuing on so again you got the
amazing team man shout out to team and i
believe it's uh patcha
forza y'all erin um
and then what am i missing i'm missing a
couple oh oh archimedes right
he's yeah he's amazing and um and bro
yeah yeah yeah see i'm good i'm good i
got i got them all
but yeah so like these are just your
gaming guys like how did the the
formation of mix up
happen it was literally just the gaming
guys now archimedes
is just someone obviously we've been
following along uh
quite a while on twitter anyway and
watching the rise of his channel and
obviously his
his feedback is the quality of his
content and everything like that but he
also makes some good points
um but he was just again it was it was a
bunch of us european guys
getting together and was like right okay
this is this is what's going to happen
and this is what i'm setting up
um but also it was the fact that it was
bringing in so many
helps uh with the the kind of numbers
week to week
all of these guys of course have got
families and sometimes people get
sidetracked if they've got kids or
have issues with kids and things like
that then one can jump in and i'll walk
and drop out and want to switch so
it's nice it's very flexible for
everybody that's coming in as well we
try to keep it that way so it's
kind of keep it as flexible as possible
again for yourselves and
and for future guests if there's times
or days that work better for the guests
depending on who we have on we
we will switch it up so we'll mix it up
as we say
uh i love the name give me the history
today
man well how did you decide that too
again it was
a we're gonna i think decide first we'll
have to decide on a day that was gonna
be best for everybody so it was uh
again the the midweek um and then mixing
it up was simply because
obviously we do mix up the chat with
anything from
random nothing to do with game and just
talking
absolute [ __ ]
[Laughter]
to to the guests we have on from
developers
to engineers community uh support
anybody from the industry and then again
other social media influencers or
podcast teams so
it was just to mix up our guests mix up
the chat makes up all content
about them so i see the vision i see the
vision brother i see when we do it
i like it right like again been
following it just to see
your rise in such a short time it's
pretty cool to see and you've had some
heavy hitters on obviously
it was honored to be on obviously me and
king came through that was a
ton of fun that was fun as well yeah ton
of fun we laughed it up
you know shot the rdx you had those guys
on and i get out we talked offline but
you know i like that you be getting
developers on i believe like i said the
song of ice game
or some of iron games excuse me that um
you had on the developer and it was
really really cool very informative i
got a lot of information so i like the
direction man
keep it up love the content and what you
guys are doing man
it's been truly you know really cool to
watch man
for sure yeah yeah it is i mean
obviously you'll know from having
kind of different uh the higher the
scale the higher the popularity the
higher
the person the harder it is to get them
kind of into these shows in the first
place so
um we have a lot of vines in the fire
fight for future people coming on
again some some harder than others some
busier than us at the moment with the
release of
systems yes um but uh i don't know
whether or not you will understand this
as well but getting anybody from
playstation that do
any talking is impossible brother
i get it all the time i'm glad you
mention it because um
you know obviously we've the lords have
earned a reputation as supposedly like a
one
preference podcast oh that's because of
me yes and i'm like
there's other lords that like other
counselors
they automatically group us that we
agree
one thousand percent with everything
they don't agree with nothing like that
so that's just that way but king is
still the first in line to get a
playstation i know that's what's funny
what is
a hilarious no you know what it is is
the fact that they
they don't like the fact that my heart
bleeds green yeah they don't like the
fact that
they don't like that i'm out here to
actively secretly revenge for my fallen
sega and somebody has to pay the price
but
at the same time i'm purchasing the
playstation 5.
and i don't care what nobody say i
respect sony all the way they made me
bend the knee
so but they they get it they get it
twisted
they don't think that we can be uh vocal
against what
other companies are doing at the same
time still being a fan
and if you don't agree with a little
hive mind mentality
then you must be against that console
you know
um when i call out uh microsoft for the
stuff that they did
you know nobody you know yeah yeah oh oh
he went at 3-4-3 let me tell you
something my dm's
with a lot of pissed-off people um but
they never you know went at me publicly
and i respect them for that
uh but they had to say yo at the end of
the day
you didn't say anything wrong right and
you know you're always championing them
so you know y'all got to give that same
respect all the way through so we we
we all around the boards we rep every
console
and if you feel that sometimes i'm going
too hard with the pause with the
you know uh phil dominance maximus are
really expensive
it's he's a really really um really
is is this the fact that y'all don't
know i've seen so many companies die
i've never seen a company come back from
the brink of death yeah
and if y'all think that this xbox wasn't
going to
die when i get to the segment of the
playstation 5
today y'all understand what i'm talking
about yeah i feel you no like i said
back to you know what dutch is saying in
reference to you know getting
all execs it is a struggle because i
i've tried
a ton of times i mean the closest we've
got was probably ben's studio
you know and you know unfortunately from
what i hear dutch again i don't know
i'm you know i'm just going about what
my experience is i can always speak for
myself but it's just like
if you're not a predominantly
playstation
only channel you know it's harder it's
harder so
um yeah so that that's the vibe but in
in general if you see across the board
right the reason i mean you can talk
about xbox all day long
xbox will pay attention and have
somebody at some point come onto your
show and talk about that
yes you could talk about playstation all
day every day for as long as you can
you'd be lucky if you get someone from
pr pr
yeah i feel and a lot of it is
transparency you know on a lot of it you
know they they're very
they protect you know their their dad's
very stuff like that they're very
protective and you know
unfortunately what me and ebantas call
it it's the hollywood game you know
numbers and stuff plays into a factor as
well
because some people when you get to a
certain point you just can't be denied
but it is what it is but hopefully yo
sony man
i'll be wanting y'all on man i'm trying
to get sucker pun tell them y'all chat
tell them
the lords would love that hey give me
yo i want i want my man
[Laughter]
he's not
don't talk to him because i'm pretty
sure that microsoft would have gave him
a bag too
and i i just honestly think that he is
for
who helped him i think his loyalty is
something totally different yeah
and i got to respect him for that
because when he was down and out dudes
was looking his way so
moving on about a question i got for
dutch man
i call you affectionately the gaming
viking you know
yeah yes so like everything you know
norse and the mythology and
everything cool so like what was the law
what was what got you to have that
association
with your gaming persona and all that
like what did that how did that whole
start and then also the history with the
name which
with your name the wondering dutch yeah
wondering dutch was
specifically because uh again uh it's
moving over from the netherlands to the
uk
um so wandering dutch was was primarily
for
a dutchman wandering around primarily
literally i do travel quite a bit i used
to had pretty cool video to travel
quite a bit um try to try to get around
the world
and see a lot of places do a lot of
things so wondering dutch was fitting
for me
um viking wise that was again
i've been primarily i've loved again
being in an area and living in an area
that's predominantly a lot of viking
history anyway
of course i live not too far a lot of
the a lot of the stuff that's in
valhalla like linda's fauna and jorvik
or
yorkers everyone knows it um that's only
a matter of an hour two hours away
maximum from where i am
um so the area itself is steeped in that
history
um again mainland europe exactly the
same thing steeped in viking history
but it was initially when uh grim frost
two of the guys that do all the apparel
and um all the weaponry and everything
for the
history show vikings um contacted me and
asked me to be
an ambassador for them um so now i think
we're about 100 strong on the
ambassadors for brimfrost
wow and they have now over a million uh
probably well over a million and a half
followers now
um but they primarily do all of the uh
again
all of this stuff for the vikings tv
show so nice
that's what kind of really got me into
it and um and got me kind of promoting
kind of
viking mythology and lore and things a
little bit more
but it's something i've always been very
very interested in
nice man like i said love is something
that's synonymous i feel
with your persona and it's cool to see
you repping every time i see valhalla
i'm like yeah my man dutch getting that
day one i already know
oh yeah i'm saying i said well you had
to saw the violence i said he in there
day one already no
because when i saw that game i was like
yo that's viking right there i'm in
i'm in on that joint you know it's the
thing another thing that surprised me a
lot about god of war though as well
yeah was the the um the the detail of
the mythology that they put into that
game
yeah um some that i didn't expect i
thought yeah they're going down the
north shore it's going down the viking
type route but then when you
actually get into it and all the stories
that you uh emir was kind of explaining
here on the little boat rides in between
sections yes um all of those are
factually correct they're all
mythological stories that are down to
the t so that's exactly how they're told
in norse law and the way they explain
things so that really took me by
surprise because i
did not expect them to go into such
detail in the kind of
the history of norse mythology in that
game
but they did i thought they would do it
uh you know justice when when i heard
that they were going in the norseman um
mythology type of way because
they did really good with greek
mythology yeah so
um i didn't think that they were uh
undercutted i thought they would do
their research they did that studio
showed that they do
really good research and i was taken
aback when uh
they fleshed out a lot of like the the
world
serpent and you know um loki's mother
and you know things of that nature like
who loki
the fenris wolf and stuff a lot of stuff
that you know i researched
on north mythology uh didn't then they
went
deeper into it you know it's really good
stuff
it's really good stuff if you take the
time out to
understand what they were trying to show
so how excited are you for ragnarok
oh extremely excited extremely i just
again
i hope it's not a watered down version
like miles morales says i really hope
this is an
actual shots fired mom's just caught a
bullet
are you are you implying are you
implying that this is a shorter
version for shorter content expansion
that we're implying
yes that is exactly what i'm saying
he's not wrong if the turnaround window
is that short
then that means that it was a large
portion of something that was cut out of
something that was originally there
and something that i've seen there like
if i see asgard
and i can't get there i'm mad as hell at
you so don't show me something on the
damn map and then talk about
you know the game is over when i was
expecting to reach that part of the map
if i can reach every part of the map
and then one section is closed off but
then you yell out we don't have no dlc
but then you tell me
that the new game is coming out in 2021
i'm like you're lying
yeah yeah painful that was painful to
see
that's exactly what i was thinking when
they announced 2021 i thought that that
turned around window was too short
yeah yeah like the game came out latter
part of 2018
yes by the time the developers have had
a break which they will have had a break
after that game
went live then they put the patches out
uh made sure everything was correct
so you're going into 2019 and you still
have
kind of bugs and patches and things
getting worked out on the original game
you're not you're not going to already
started pre-production on the next
good point yeah and that that's the
point unless it's on
playstation 4 natively oh my god
that's another thing i believe we're
getting messy now
are we are we implying that this is a
strategy
i'll happily play it on playstation if i
have no issues but you know
you know tell the truth shame the devil
you know what it is is when this is what
i don't like what's going on
it's that was good customer service yeah
if you're saying that that we're going
to support you all the way through
yeah um you know and and then what the
hell like if if you if you're gonna get
a playstation five yeah you're gonna get
the bells and the whistles like right
you're gonna get the apex predator of
what we have going on right but again
also if you have a pro and if you have a
slimmer you've been down with us
you are still rocking and i think
especially right now they i don't think
they really understand the pulse of the
the of what's going on no they're
difficult
they actually are i i firmly believe
that that was their strategy as well but
when they saw
xbox get the negative reaction that's
what i'm talking about
yeah from the halo infinite news as far
as it being supported
right that the xbox the base xbox would
be holding
it back right so then the hole in the
back matter started and it was a
big negative thing from the media thus i
think that made them apprehensive to say
well that's kind of
well let's see again
see this is the difference this is what
i see when when
sony does something that's not favorable
but microsoft is doing the same thing
and if sony comes out and says the first
which really never happens but
you know let's say microsoft supports
them right yo we're doing that
as well it pushes the community forward
they put that narrative out
what tony would do is like oh they got
punched in the face yeah we're not going
no
let me go over there and curb stomp them
while they're down
the opposite that's what the generation
talks but enough we we
are diverging
i gotta ask the question because we got
some topics today but i gotta ask the
question that we asked all the lords
in the realm i need lord dutch's top
video game top five video games or
franchises of all time
uh final fantasy franchise is the top
for me oh
100 um that goes all the way back to
the nes which final fantasy oh here we
go
see all the way back so if you're going
on on original retro
final fantasies then final fantasy 6 is
king
i don't like hearing song man you do it
too much
yeah he's a six he's a six guy you're a
six i'm a three guy
if you're going on a kind of new era
then seven
and nine mommy but so but you you're
you're a catholic guy you're a catholic
guy yeah
okay fine now fair enough so uh look at
that dizzy speak on it
look at the fake church going on
fake final fantasy 6 church going on in
the chat
we got it preach yo shout out to slow mo
i see you in there
oh i was gonna say so okay so we got the
final fantasy franchise give me some
four more games
an entire franchise mainly the originals
of course we know it's went off on a
little bit of a
downward turn recently um but
the again you can't you cannot discount
that
that halo multiplayer when it first came
out specifically and the co-op in halo 2
uh when halo 2 had the full club
finished yes
yes beautiful shout out to so many
memories oh yes
oh yeah um the original gears of war
when that came out specifically when it
was two v2s
yeah v2s on multiplayer was i remember
so many nights playing just without the
whole wall hopping and wall sliding and
things like that yes
such a good game originally and that
that not to cut you
from the campaign i always feel the
original gears
had a darker tone yes and i always feel
like not that they got too kitty and
jokey but
i remember king remember scenes like the
krill for the first time
it was almost like it was like a horror
game and then
when you fought the berserker for the
first time
like the game scared you okay i believe
the difference between that was
marketing right
and they market the game as a bloody
gory yeah you know
shootout fest like you know cover base
and you had to cover because
you were unfair like you know but you
were still
you know fighting the fair so when they
did that that
that that commercial uh hello doc
oh yes yes what right and then you
started the game off and used it and you
wasn't uh locked up and it was
maybe before the creatures running at
the top it was giving you tingles and
stuff like that
when they went away from it is when they
brought color into the world remember
the
color was muted yes yes
yes love that scene
yeah so um i think they're gonna go back
to that i think
this after the storyline here i think
they're gonna um
shed that storyline as far as the colors
go and go back to that dark muted scary
type of gears
and i think they need to i think they
need to reinvent gears back to
where its base was the same way kratos
reinvented it some people hated i don't
really like god of war like that
up into how the old one is but
i i knew it needed the direction change
and it worked
[Music]
forward to motorsport is is an app the
absolute pinnacle of
simulation racing absolutely horizon is
on another level like horizon is the
racing game for everybody yes
yep and for me too much for me
horizon you know why i say it's too much
because it makes me feel like i'm
playing grand theft auto with all the
stuff to do
oh you're overwhelmed yeah the map is
crazy
and then i got to take a break i'm like
like you got to go get this race over
here but if you want to make sure that
you go over here to do this and you're
like
but i do i saw something over here
though but i just love the fact that
you're not restricted like you can
go anywhere and then for you know for
trash racers like me that rewind feature
and so dutch are you talking about the
entire series are you the entire series
series no again four being in the uk is
brilliant
but three was also brilliant being in
australia loved that game and again the
expansions have been crazy as well
yo you're doing well on the expansion no
dutch they love you others
they said this dude is the greatest
guest of all time it was
real his list yo everybody slo-mo you
have not said one game that people were
like oh my god
he's spitting the hot wheels expansion
oh crazy crazy yeah
crazy but let's dutch you tell us why
horizon horizon so if you remember if
you remember when horizon was first
unveiled in the
the trailer that the first kind of
showed off of that the first unveiling
of the of the original horizon was what
set it off it was the feel of it feel of
the festival vibes and you have all this
music playing
yeah and it wasn't just a case of just
any old music that had the top artists
the sdgs yes on everything and they've
only expanded that further as well so
they've got radio stations pretty much
for everybody no matter what you like
yeah top to bottom but then they've got
different areas they've expanded it
instead of being just one area of it
couldn't be they've said right okay now
we're doing
australia and we've implemented several
different parts of australia into one
map
and then in the uk again we've got the
lake district we've got edinburgh we've
got
other parts of scotland we've got the
kind of over down in the cotswolds we've
got everything
congregated into one but i also believe
that
that is as big as they can go for that
game on current hardware
i think if they could go far because if
you if you have a look at
the crew which tried to do it yes but
didn't do it to the same effect
that was too much world not enough
actual race and mechanics because
the handling of the cars were horrific
right
and then the detail of the world as well
was let down mm-hmm
whereas horizon was a happy medium for
the hardware of its time
this time yeah yeah yeah beautiful
graphics
great detail top to bottom unbelievable
detail on the cars
customizability and then plenty of
content and then the map size was just
right it
wasn't too big it wasn't too small but
they implemented a lot in it whereas the
first the crew was the
entire usa you know yeah that was too
much
i think for me as as somebody who loved
project gotham
yes yeah kudos
oh my god bring back pgr but or bring it
back
playground games understand how the game
design goes
that's exactly what i'm saying
and one final game i think you're
missing right one more
one one final game again i mentioned it
but it's what started off kind of my
my love of of gaming in the first place
and that was age of empires
okay
i think i was the only dude at the pc
show when they showed
[Applause]
not just the single player campaign but
the the that was one of the first games
as well where it had
full mod support from the community
top to bottom everybody could do
anything they wanted on that game create
maps and game types and
different types of multiplayer
experiences but you could just download
and just
implement into the game with no issue
and play online with
hundreds of thousands of people yeah man
it's tremendous
it's so cool to see it come over and get
the attention and the love you know i'm
saying
console we got to get it hopefully could
the quick time frame
give you the topics yes
people don't realize how important that
is to see you on a console in
a quicker turnaround because generally
like you said dutch those games would
always be pc only and
you know would never come and i come
from the rts i love the turn-based type
stuff
and to see that genre get represented
you know all consoles pretty dope yo man
chad they they love it
i mean disney's like yo we found
addict's replacement
you want to get to see what you have
before we get into the finals oh yeah
first we have
lag three with the five dollar super
chat uh please say something and then
the following
yeah it's lag three with the five
thousand chat yo dutch it's rhett's
it's [ __ ] dad love to see your growth
uh
and you have to show your controller yes
which one
yeah that's true which one there are
many controller
there are many facts absolutely no doubt
and final question
lord dutch favorite console
of all time pressed or present and
why i like that one that red and black
and you can't say pc because we know
it's pc yeah oh
yeah i like that one talk talk that's
where people can see it
yeah oh he got to say something
put the focus on it put him up one more
time put him up one more time does those
fire yeah oh wow
that's crazy i like that black and red
though that's like that
chicago ball one right side
put a three under put a 33 on it for
kids
give me a number one for d for d rose
and i'm in
that's fire so let me ask you this again
no pc got no pc is your
your home your appreciation but we gotta
talk console now
what's your favorite console of all time
past the present
it's a difficult one because there's a
lot again being back on final fantasy
favorites
uh the one that i used to follow in
again the the nez
and the the old rhett rule um
it is a real toss-up between 360 and
playstation 1.
i'll say playstation 1 because when
final fantasy 7 etc first release
talk tom talk to him now
talk to slow talk to solve talk to dizzy
talk about the the impact of uh
final fantasy 7 on playstation here we
go let's go let's go
let's go let's talk about the best ones
let's talk about the best one
shush you you had your moment you had
your moment kefka
now we get to talk that cloud strife
that's sephiroth let's go
yeah the original the original
unfiltered
whole story in one game over four days
let me let me give you
on to something go ahead keep talking
and also play that thing consecutively
every night after school jumping homes
thirsting
on a big old massive screen
chunky tv yeah plug it in play it disc
in there we go
make sure the disc was clean
blue on the lens
and then when you when you finish that
one this and it said insert this two
seconds
too bad
cog plays the cw final fantasy game
listen man listen to dutch you see the
enthusiasm where they say seven you see
the energy
it's different right if you were to
compare games though
which one is better but we asking
we're asking about impact he could talk
he can't answer that he could answer
that story
story-wise six is about a story
gameplay-wise seven is about a game
yeah and they're always about the game
players
[Laughter]
gameplay six reimagined
is the most divisive because of the fact
that
you had the way it was marketed yeah you
had people go purchase a playstation go
get that game thing it was
action
it was an action game and their first it
was their first jrpg man
i thought it it had the largest impact
for
the reason of that's when sony grabbed
nintendo by the neck
very aggressive move yeah because to see
a square rpg
it was not supposed to happen yeah new
console
cd i mean it's tremendous but yeah but
that's a good one man good with dr got a
god of respect
you know what i'm saying shout out to
you it's like i cried with the flower
girl died see it's the impact man
everybody knows spoilers spoilers
really look if you ain't playing final
fantasy by this time i don't know what
to tell you i'm playing a new one um
when it come out on xbox i mean by that
point you might have part two and you
might get out of the first city
yeah right finally get out of bed
your dream happened and phil might
purchase square enix
oh here we go
[Laughter]
history tremendous god of respect so
we're gonna get into the show
last week's pro results are in and the
people have spoken to the question
with the recent tear down and back
compat information reveal of the ps5
what is the next most important thing
you want revealed before the console
drops on november the winner
of our three-way ilp poll at 46
of the vote was the messy lords
i don't care the playstation 5 is
getting delayed until i see digital
foundry with the console
in their heads this is i gotta give it
to king
king man his influence is crazy
coming in at second place at 30 percent
of the vote was i need to see the
playstation 5 ua ui
and what changes features have been
added which we eventually did get
and last place at 23 of the vote was i
need to see back compat
contested on different games to see the
performance benefits group
shout out to all the lords who
participated lord
king your messy lords have hijacked
the polls once again what's your
thoughts
i believe it's going to be delayed
[Laughter]
i'm not going to find though once i saw
the user interface i was like okay
they showed a little bit of things but
again at the same time
he did it again in the close of a state
of play
like i'm like you dudes are so
controlling
like let the kids out to play let the
kids have to play
and you don't want to let them out to
play because you know they're going to
be exposed to what's going on in these
streets and we're going to find out what
they really know
our team my team's stand up put the
favorites in there let's get
check out for the new poll that's coming
at the end of this show but we are going
to move on
lord sav speaking of said ui
what is going on in the world in
playstation man you are up yeah we
finally as lord king said that poll
aids badly
we got a ui reveal for the playstation
5.
um so honestly from my point of view
i like the fact that it's very simple i
like the fact that it seems
quick and snappy and speedy so um we had
a lot of differing sort of opinions on
about it that i saw online um where
your gamer went as far as saying that
it's probably a game changer other
people just
liking the fact that it's so simple and
apparently snappy
so the biggest change that i see to the
ui
um from what we have now on playstation
4 is that uh when you hit the
playstation button and you go to the
control panel the control panel
actually pops up as what they call sort
of cards
um but you still stay in game unlike the
playstation 4
when you hit the ps button it takes you
back to like sort of the main menu
and then you go back into the game so
what happens is when you go to the
control panel
these cards come up that uh initially
it'll show you different things it'll
show you uh
specifically for the game that you're
playing it'll show you different
activities in the game that you that you
might have a percentage of finished or
you haven't gotten to yet
or you may have skipped over um and the
cool part about that is that apparently
you
you will be able to jump from place to
place within that game
or say let's say you finish the game and
you're trying to go back to get the
platinum trophy and you haven't
you don't know exactly what it is you
have to do rather than have to go
and search the trophies the activities
will show you the percentage of that
trophy that you've gotten
and it'll in all likelihood take you to
the exact place in the game where you
need to go to get it yeah
that's very cool if it works in in
practice right um
one thing that i sort of gleaned from
this is that not every game
is going to be optimized for this and
it's going to be upon development
up to the developer so again it's one of
those things that it's like when you
leave it up to the devs
they're going to make sure they finish
their game first and foremost
so my hope is that they do integrate the
stuff because it seems very cool
but at the end of the day i think
playstation has to do more to make sure
that this
user experience is controlled by them on
the console side
and they do that work because otherwise
a lot of these features will just be
lost
and i think realistically it's going to
it's going to fall on first party only i
think
they're partly going to really implement
it it absolutely really is so um
i think these features are cool and
again the fact that they still maintain
a a sort of snappy ui the fact that they
separate
games now from other media and it's not
all just
like one long crossbar i i enjoy that as
well the fact that the playstation store
is
integrated into the ui now the system
rather than a separate app
which uh honestly since i my playstation
is just for exclusives i never really
saw it slow down
right maybe up until now right because
now the whole the whole
generation's worth of exclusives are on
my sort of front page
and i see it slowing down a little bit
but when you jump into the playstation
store
it sort of takes a minute for the stuff
to populate yeah yeah
it's very slow so the fact that this guy
is going to be integrated at the console
level i think is very cool
um so i like it i like it it's simple
it's not
it's not trying to do too much it's
trying to sort of condense and simplify
the things that they had already
uh done with the playstation 4's ui um
it's
it's it it should get the job done so we
will see
we will see if these features become
game changers or if they just become
do you mean the old school picture in
picture you'd be the staff
that's map
so to the snap feature right you have
the snap before where apparently
you can watch something
picture-in-picture you can watch game
play of a particular section
that you're having trouble with or
something like that um and it's
something
that the xbox had and got rid of because
it was sucking too many resources from
[Music]
so this is something that playstation
has sort of brought back
and we'll see obviously these systems
should have the overhead to be able to
run this stuff without issues
right we'll we will see
but but beyond that stuff i'm just glad
that they showed it
yes that's where dynamic scaling comes
into effect
4k hdr you i absolutely need that
okay so get the super chatter that would
get dutch hold on because i was i was on
the
let's go yeah i got pixel bit i see here
let me get him okay
with the 5 super chat i think devs will
implement it as long as the achievement
when uh when created requires a location
point
also good it's only biting snapchat
messy
so then dutch bank obviously we got a
chance to see the the ui reveal
playstation 5 finally got a glimpse
you know what is what's your thoughts on
it man how you feeling about it
it couldn't have been worse than what
they've already got oh damn dutch
damn the facts it is
despise it and again it's talking
it's not just not just from a normal ui
point because i think it just looks
cluttered anyway the way it's done
um much like the xbox one used to be
very cleared
not very snappy things were all over the
place
but from the store point of view like
you pointed out
like uh it's the store is shocking
it's slow and you it's a struggle to
find anything
um but speaking to a lot of indie devs
as well one of the key
key things for playstation store is the
indie game could drop on that store
and you would struggle to even find them
on the day of launch on the day of life
you can find their game yeah visibility
is always a problem yeah in the bushes
they need to tidy that up so badly they
need to have a section
dedicated to indie games like xbox two
fair enough fair enough was there was
there anything that impressed you
was there anything that you liked about
this ui it's it's smooth and snappy it
needs to be
okay the extra power again that these
consoles have you would expect that at
this point so it's not something that
impresses it's something that is
required
gotcha um gui i didn't have state this
again the g
dub on twitter they can like it
it's a ui at the end of the day the ui
needs to be quick and snappy i don't
care whether or not it's 4k
or 1080. oh we get to get into
because i'm not playing on the dashboard
i'm playing games
as long as that dashboard is reactive
smooth snappy gets is what i need to do
one could argue that you could those
resources would be better used in games
oh right and i've asked a few developers
for this as well and they
confirmed that is the case oh exclusive
okay all right
gotcha smoking that just feels strongly
about it
elsewhere fair enough sir fair enough
lord
king i'm very curious about your
playstation 5
ui impressions well
you know um jin dance moves ryan was
definitely right
what they do believe in generations
of ui
because i'm pretty sure the ui is not
going to change on the playstation 4 pro
oh my god all right so okay so this is
my take away from it
it is about time
that they caught up it is about time
that was my biggest barrier with the
playstation 4 and i every time i turn it
on i realize why i hate it so much
jesus when i hit the playstation button
that second of pause to go into
something else and it takes me out of
the experience
see when i hit the xbox button it'll
bring up my
the side menu and i see my friends and
my stuff like that and if i want to go
to the store i go to the store and i'll
pull it up and i go here and there
then i can go right back to quick resume
in my game that i'm doing right now this
is not on the series x
s s or x this is on my xbox one right
now
so all the stuff that these dudes is
like yo i'm tell you me and
yo and then you sort of feature with the
whole snap the stuff
you said we've been doing that the stuff
that we practiced on and did already
that realized that it was absolutely
useless so we did away with it because
it was eating up too much of the ui
and we needed to have it snappy fast and
quick this
was uh epiphany for playstation dudes
right so so this is for the playstation
dude that's never gonna buy an xbox
all right this is for the playstation do
what you saw was
the reason why mark cerny definitely
wanted us a super fast
ssd because he hated that playstation
uh user interface as much as i did and
and
he went inside there and he said yo we
got to get the best engine
for our uh ssd that we could ever get
because
i hate this i hate this and i know he
did
and and you got to thank for his hate to
get you that fast ssd he didn't care
about what was going on he said i don't
care how
big the fan gotta be you put that fan in
there
you you get you get some what we need
liquid cooling get the liquid
put the liquid
that's how you say it
and then somebody said yo make it 4k
why
[Laughter]
we ain't gonna do 4k games but we can do
4k interfaces
[Laughter]
it's just the fact that one i like the
fact that it was snappy
all right i like the fact that they had
little cards and little things going do
i think
over a period of time some of those
features will be lost the playstation
is notorious for trying things and if
it's not supported in some form or
fashion they drop it remember the
controller where you was able to
do all this and fly and move yeah and
yeah they they threw that to the bushes
oh yeah i believe that dual sense
control uh
if it gets too much hate is going to
revert into
a dual shock four or five or whatever
the hell
later you know down the road you've been
designing the day in
invent gimmicky things yes to get you in
to rope you into the console and i
believe that you know that snap feature
will be there
if a developer supports it if they
notice that it's not
and it's a good thing because that can
take them away from
take the views away from youtube because
a lot of times
i see what this generation does if they
get stuck in a game they
go right to youtube you know they have
no grit to work it out
sony knows this and sony can use that
traffic now what i don't like is
talk to me you must be a subscriber of
playstation plus now that's a good thing
and that's a bad thing it's a good thing
that they're getting you into
playstation plus
you have to integrate that in with the
playstation now i think they need to
make that step and to make that happen
to grow that base but
if the function doesn't work as
advertised right across the boards
right what's the sense of playstation
plus so you must like mandate it to
every
every developer you know you must
support this feature
because if uh half of your game support
it then half of the people's gonna buy
playstation plus
right you know that want that feature
because let's say you're waiting for
valhalla
and then you get it but it's not a first
person for uh
first uh party title right and it
doesn't support that feature to the max
how you want it
and you're trying to get to this
achievement but you can see that you
have 33 percent for that achievement
but you can't see how to get that
achievement you understand
so that will uh infuse it frustration in
the game player because they know they
can play big sack boy pause
and that's disgusting
you can play big sack boy exactly
i gotta put bigger like this
[Laughter]
oh it's that boys
[Laughter]
so you can find out where to get the
church inside
that boy but you you can't you know find
out where to get a certain moon or
whatever from valhalla
that will uh form a level of frustration
in the game player so
i think if they get a lot of backlash
with that they they gotta work at it
as a as a base it's a mandate you know
to to make sure developers do support
that feature
and if they do it might take off but my
biggest thing that i took away from it
was the fact that it was snappy
it was quick yeah and it removed that
barrier away from me
that i had before with the regular
playstation because
playstation dudes let me tell you guys
right now
if you've never played on an x or on
xbox
you won't understand how the ease of use
and the jump in between
games because they're using quick resume
and all that stuff
at this moment right and you won't know
what's the difference until you get a
chance to experience it
and if you do you might prefer that
ecosystem
over the uniball that you have right now
like that one bar thing go across
there yeah it's whatever but i don't
think they're going to put that in the
playstation 4 and i think that's the
only
generational thing that they believe in
right we're fair enough
we've got we got a member of the realm
and we've got a new stupid yeah so we've
got
the liz 22 with the five dollar super
chat all this ps5 xbox ui talk has me
feeling like alan iverson
in here talking about you ah
absolutely i like that that was good
that was good
all right you are talking about a minute
and salute and welcome to the realm none
of your business none of your business
man
salute man welcome throw the crash throw
the horns in there man for man put the
horns in there yeah
actually we got wow we got a couple we
got a bunch yeah okay then we have
smithy smith with the two dollar super
chat
hi i'm big sack boys
who did that for you you've killed this
with that bro we have a clutch man with
the two dollars
outcast is making the dlc daddy fat
stuck
yo yo let me get black brody with the
[ __ ]
a little sad boy got an album coming out
with little baby
and the baby caught straight in the bush
that big sack boy talked got the road
[Laughter]
oh wow oh we got an og stackboard
yo we got an og put the crutch up in the
room bogus creek man put them up in
there
put the crust in there oh my god
iop oh gee let me tell you something
you you definitely jumped in at the
right time because we're about to
uh get these sweepstakes going and um
let you know who's the winner for this
uh xbox series x
and uh the playstation 5. that's this is
a proper time man
nick somebody holiday uh joy
feels good to see vogue vogel's been
repping us for a long time man
it's a little vogel man let me get my
bars off oh yeah but look it's
unlike it looks like oh dutch and king
i actually liked it i thought it was
cool minimalistic yeah yeah you did like
it you just said you liked it
dutch didn't seem to be impressed one
thing one thing i wanted to change on
the playstation that would be so easy
instead of pressing the long hold to get
your menu on the side open
much like xbox xbox that's it i said
that's it yeah
that's what gig was saying i agree but
it said and as soon as i turn on the
playstation the first thing i
accidentally do every time
is playstation button once that
dashboard yeah
yeah yeah yeah
brother yo let's get this super chat
before i get my blog we got
the black writer with the final super
chat maybe sac boy was lost in
translation
we have donald trump with the two dollar
super chat how many more subs into the
big sack
we up for new emoji too
chat yo king so sony ui is 4k hdr but
their games ain't
hmm
oh my god like i said
i thought it was cool obviously the 4k
ui
you know hdr kind of popped but to your
credit you know we definitely would love
to see those
you know allocated probably towards
resources but hey you know one thing i
will say about themsolve like they're
very good with their dynamic themes and
stuff
so i always felt like even now with my
my tv i couldn't see with the with the
cx
it really pops man this stuff really
really pops so
you just got tv with dude yeah i got tv
with it
cause they dashboard do pop better than
xbox doing it
you know what i said you know what i'm
saying like
you know you got to be above that level
you know what it says
get a chance to see that hdr they don't
get that greatness y'all get that
greatness man so looks that feature
returns you know that was interesting to
see
um you know i definitely missed that
feature from xbox i used to
actually used to use it a lot you know
with uh with the achievements and
certain other little things
tips and tricks and then even the video
apps i used to like that the video apps
you could do that with that shout out to
the whole vcr xbox one that was doing
that
you know what i'm saying but um yeah i
don't know how i feel about the card
system i'm gonna be honest um
i like that it's it's very like as far
as resource it comes up quick and stuff
but i kind of feel soft is very spoilery
you're like you notice how they hit the
loading time with the ssd
what were they fast forward
apparently they were talking about that
they they're they're they have certain
things
you can again again this would be on a
developer-to-developer basis but it's
something where the developing program
and say look
uh this is going to jump you to a place
that is spoilery
right and for whatever reason it somehow
they're able to tell you that
um but again i that's one of those
things like if you're looking for tips
and tricks
in a in a sort of bespoke uh sort of ui
program and not doing it on your own
just going on youtube
you don't know what what sort of how
they program that right
it's up to the developer yeah no doubt i
mean i guess what i worry about is like
i'm coming from a you know multiplayer
or a competitive thing like
because obviously they got the thing
with the snap and then they got the
thing where you could watch your man
playing like i don't want to be playing
cod and i could
be your man looking at somebody else's
screen yo they over there
like that better now be implemented when
i originally saw it
when before they went into detail about
what it was i immediately
i thought to stadia i was like are they
trying to do the stadia where you can
you can go to a part in the game and
then give it off to somebody or
you know so you know again i don't think
you don't if you don't have cloud
computing behind that you can't really
do that it's very difficult to do
um but yeah i mean it's like i said it's
one of those things that
as a new thing is like oh wow but it
remains to be seen if it if at the end
of the generation we're looking at that
as something that's just the norm now
right or if it's something that just
fell to the wayside yeah i mean and back
to like i said
you know the whole thing with with that
i just it's going to be up to the
developer
how to implement i just don't want too
much spoilery i don't want nobody seeing
somebody else's game play why are you in
a multiplayer match
fighting against some team and they all
looking at each other's screen and they
talk about yogi over there
that i know it's probably not that's
like i'm being exaggerated but i'm just
saying like
yeah imagine if it makes it let you jump
to a part in the game you haven't gotten
to yet like yeah
like i don't want to see none of that so
i mean again that that's that
um back to the 4k joint i agree
wholeheartedly with dutch though
you know xbox one x had 4k uh ui
dashboard but they rolled it back to
1080p
and i'm all about the developers getting
the extra resources that to me is more
important
that trump i mean we're not living in
the ui
we're living in the game so you just
said that the ui
on the playstation pop no i mean that's
the strength it does
i'm not gonna say it does it because
it's about like the movement of the uh
the
the backgrounds right because the
dynamic themes that
sony does dynamics on
you just had to do a secondary app and
download the secondary app and he was
able to get dynamic backgrounds they're
on one of my xboxes that's downstairs
but um yeah i know i feel exactly what
you're talking about but even you what
you said there was
that you saw that it popped yeah yeah
but
i think that the reason why microsoft
scaled it back is because they were
doing
they actually believe in generations and
um
you know your phone is not 4k um going
into the user
interface your uh your og
xbox which they actually support uh well
not og but the first xbox one you know
the big fat you know vcr joint
that is not total interfaith you know so
i believe that they're supporting that
across the boards and they're using that
unilaterally
to make sure that all that stuff works
whereas playstation this is really
their their joint they really separating
uh
the interfaces because the card system
won't be available on your playstation
4.
so all these features and stuff that
they're doing here
this is where they're supporting
generations this is where
jim dance moves ryan words are practical
and
uh yeah it's more of a jump i agree
you won't be able to partake over here
and over here you would but i i heard
what you said when you when you said
that their joint is more visually
pleasing
yeah your 4k television and do you think
that direction is
is better for them i mean yeah i think i
think it
fits with their ecosystem like they're
all about the exclusives
the dynamic themes the presentation when
i get go sushima
like that dynamic theme pops the joints
moving the cherry blossoms is going to
me
like they're all about promoting that so
it really fits with them
like almost like a movie presentation
that it's the highest quality
in that dashboard you know i think sony
fans appreciate that you know what i'm
saying
whereas for us again i'm not knocking
because i from what i hear that series x
stuff is to be determined they're not
locking themselves down to the 1080p
but if it was up to me i would say yo
don't get caught up in that
leave the resources for the games and
give that a resource allotment to the
developer
because at the end of the day i'd rather
the games perform
way better you know and i will say this
i feel that the ui on the playstation 5
probably the best example of the ssd
with the multitasking
and the going back and forth and the
party and stuff like that
so you know look at the end of the day i
thought it was cool good interaction and
stuff like that
my only thing that they haven't answered
and king you know i'm about i got to get
at them
one thing i hate about playstation's
dashboard and their ui
is they got to talk about the install
and the patching
because i don't want to see that
downloading
then installing like that two-step
process is the worst like i i please
hope
that all the new features have improved
that because xbox is a one pack one one
process state
download install it's ready to go i
don't think they fixed that yeah that
got to go because i
cannot stay you wait so long you know
sometimes i get free wish of sashima was
the worst one for me
yeah it didn't even tell us that i had
the game
partially uninstalled like i got up the
first first part of the game
completed and then stopped it was like
okay the rest of it's got download now
yeah
what here we go here we go
my worst one was um what was it the
it was the metal gear solid five i think
and that joint took them 24 hours
and you know what ends up happening i
end up getting frustrated
i switch hdmi inputs i play xbox and
then i forget to go back
to the game because i was waiting
i mean with me it was always the remote
install the remote install would never
would never work and then i come back to
my system and be like your system
would shut off improperly and i'm like
what like what's going on with the
remote background
downloading so they're downloading
hopefully wi-fi
six and then working with azure servers
something
got to be improved because that part no
one talks about that with playstations
you interface
and it really bothers me
anyway let's get to super chat before we
move on we have a
vocals creek with the 5 chat i was going
to do it for the last week
last few weeks but i was working and mr
show live glad i caught this week's show
thank you brother it's good to see you
then we have the wise old gamer with the
2 super chat with the 4k
ui playstation has no love for their tcl
fan base
let me get chris because even though he
put it in color he said i can't believe
oh my god that can't be a real complaint
cog
all you got to do is check the game
download and see where the download's at
then you can play another place that you
feel korean while the download take but
here's the problem when you come to the
xbox ecosystem
there's none of that you don't have to
you can wait you can play another game
but the difference is when you download
and install
the install it's already installed
you're telling the dude that drives a
hugo
tower ferrari moves like you don't know
you don't know about that life you don't
know about it
ferrari life leave as you go like it
would be different if
it'd be different if you install if you
download it on the playstation
and they just went directly into the
game like you're saying the xbox does it
all in one shot so even if it is
happening
it's not showing you that it's happening
right and overall
it's still snappier because downloads on
my playstation and the download speeds
yes no you go into your downloads and
then you have to it's it's kind of like
a crap shoot like i if i get a slow
download speed i'll stop and start it
again
and i'll get a faster download speed
yeah it is literally like this this sort
of like a
roulette wheel type thing and it's like
it's it's like it's almost like it's
being throttled and no one
talks about that playstation
i mean it's a legit complaint man like
dude
otherwise old gamer i got that then we
have welcome to the realm the ain't
i'm an ancient gamer shout out to put
the quest in the chat for the 8th
gamer this old game is live oh geez
coming out the footwork that's what's up
with that playstation 2.
and we have king duvey with the two
dollar super chat
screen sniping will be worse with the
snap features
you're talking about cheating guys i
guess
yeah exactly thanks then we have smitty
smith with the five dollar super chat
it's good that the playstation fan base
finally got something at 4k
oh wow yeah who did that for you the
book of
ex we got to hit him with the book right
then we have uh
victor allisteen with the two dollar
super chat this ui about to become a
card reader
savage and what else do we have we have
whatever we got
today before that yeah we got
forte again say with the uh five dollars
which had finally secured my xbox series
x
i was nervous hell now i can make my
hype video for launch plus you know we
board when we talking about ui for a
week
we're just waiting in the wings um that
we have welcome to the realm lord
suicide kings
put the crest in the chapel crest up
there thank you sir
hold on wise old gamer yes for sure um
we're gonna do a redesign on a couple of
things anyway some new stuff coming in
the realm you can check with the new
controller
yeah yeah there's some stuff that needs
to be addressed there shall we
um then we have jean rock louis with the
two dollars
snitch station 5.
wow with a 6-9 headband
wow they are listening and they are
watching then we have uh there we have
buddha time with the frog
yo you open up the playstation boxing
and go trayway
yo you stupid movie going
and then we have stitch with the two
dollar super chat what does king have to
do for the four hundred dollar tier
oh oh oh come on
who put that who put that that was
[ __ ] good that's
your stick yo hey my guy what's up with
you
already got a tattoo now then we got the
wise little gamer with the two dollar
super chat where's attic did the
playstation 4k ui
knock him out
adding to the bushes y'all then we have
the liz 22 with the five dollar super
chat
can't wait for scooby-doo in the game to
rip the mask off jim ryan's head to
reveal it's been don matrix the entire
time i would have got away with it if it
wasn't for these silly kids
we've got that i think we got all our
bars off with the ui
ready to move on um yeah man so this was
addict's topic and i want to get into
the rub
um series s some 900p
forget about it gotta talk about it
gotta talk
about it man so uh yeah it looks like
yakuza like a dragon once again back in
the news um yeah man so it looks like
they they revealed as far as what it's
going to run on series that's going to
have two graphic modes
one that runs at 1440p and 30 frames per
second and the other
at 900p and 60 frames so that's right
if you want 60 you got to go down to
900p so we got to talk about it man uh
this was definitely a concern over on
the internet what's going on with the
series this
is a series s thing is it a developer
thing so uh let's get you in service
i'm actually dutch excuse me let's get
dutch in first um dutch man where are
you at with this whole
um reveal of the specs on on yakuza
uh yakuza as far as as far as i know
especially from the history of yakuza
it's never been a technically
outstanding game anyway
right in terms of development um
of course the game itself is going down
a different direction um
series s it it's a again it's an
e it's an entry console for xbox i'm not
going to be
threatened about 900p on an entry
console
if it's 60 frames a second again it
has its own upscaling so it won't look
horrific but
it is what it is it's it's partly
developer partly console
um again that game did it
it's a third party so so if it was
up to you like based on again no we're
not developers here but
do you contribute you attribute it more
to
the development or developers still
being unfamiliar
with the series s and maybe they still
have to learn it what what what do you
think oh no
i don't i don't attribute it to the
hardware itself i think
yakuza as a franchise has never been
technically outstanding anyway
um so i don't i mean even if you have a
look at the current ones there's
there might have been fun there's some
people again some people love yakuza
some people hate it
um but it's never been a technically
outstanding game and that's not going to
change this gym
i mean it might be a fun game it's
certainly a wacky game
is it off the walls yes um but it's
never technically outstanding
that's but it's not what they're known
for they never it's
[Music]
so absolutely i feel you on that dude i
hear where you coming from lord
soft man 900 people i thought we were
done with 900 peace off
let's welcome to the realm lord eyeball
eyeball to the realm
put the crash off for your brother man
put him up man i don't think he wanted
to say evil
it's evil evil i will i thought he was
going uh no no he he wanted to say evil
but
you know evil you know yes
that's right um so 900p look uh
like uh like dutch said uh this
particular engine
which they call the dragon engine is uh
it's
always been sort of kind of taxing on
hardware
not never necessarily the best optimized
game so it's always been sort of tough
so when you're looking at a game that a
third-party game that's being put
on you know multiple skus and you do
have to think about
you know the limitations of the series s
you know as if phil spencer did say like
listen i realize this is
it's it's not like a cut and pasting you
don't have to do the work to address
both skus
so it's work that needs to be done and
you know
at the launch of the console we saw this
at the launch of this past generation
that you saw certain games that you knew
could run at 1080p but just they just
weren't optimized for that
whether the games are coming in really
hot or whatever the case may be because
if you look in comparison
there's certain games that run it even
higher than the 1440p
that the the series s is touting
particularly we're talking about the
falconer
yeah that runs that you know 1800 p 60
frames per second
on the uh on the series s so i it's
developer to developer
um and i just don't think it the extra
work that they would need to put in to
get it there
um at a higher resolution doesn't make
sense for
for getting it out at this point in less
than a month so maybe we see a patch for
that later on i don't think it's a huge
deal again
when it comes to the series that's the
series s is always about making those
concessions
in order to hit what you want out of
next gen which would be frame rate
which would be the ray tracing and stuff
like that so
whatever the resolution you get and i
and i think we talked about this when
they officially announced the series s
we had a
dealer talk about it and we had did
profoundly talk about it it said in
practice
you the the series s is probably more
along the lines of a 1080p
60 fps console than the 1440p yeah
absolutely
so i think that's what it is and this
don't fret
if you want to see it higher then get a
series x
i mean but if you're still going to get
you know in the games to support ray
tracing the game support all that stuff
you'll get those features with the
series s so i think the value is still
there
i don't think it diminishes value at all
no doubt lord king
i thought we were done man not on the p
what happened
i mean that's not something i ever want
to address
you got real presidential you got real
presidential
that's something i ever want to talk
about
profit of xbox what's going on man i
thought it was 14
40 120 hurts every day the fact that
you're bringing up these
inconsistencies i mean i have to address
them in in the proper manner and i will
say
this is not final code um
until final code is released and we can
actually talk about it but
it indicates that it is the only people
talking about uh resolution is the
people that uh
have tvs that can't even report
so the fact that the tcl life uh
is definitely prevalent inside society
and the toxicity
that is on twitter is uh talking about
this 900p
i'm shame on you we play with the bass
though
but what i'm gonna say is this right the
game look like shenmue
uh it doesn't look like shenmue 2020.
i'm not gonna lie and say that i'm not
excited that the game is launching on
the xbox platform
because it's a traditionally uh you know
asian market game uh uh centered on a
playstation platform
so the fact that this is over here i
don't care if it's at
720p i wasn't getting that version
anyway but
i'm just saying that it it is a cool
for microsoft to even be mentioned with
uh a lot of these yeah
i do like so having your cool set launch
exclusive exclusive tools absolutely so
i'm gonna say this if anyone has an
issue with the 900p
don't buy an s yeah just just don't buy
an s
and then when the game um is playing on
your
xbox you know then you can play it at
the highest resolution if it's in
performance mode because i heard it had
a couple of other modes so
whenever that game does come out and and
i hold sega's feet to the fire
tell them to change the engine why are
they not using unreal engine i think
unreal engine will be a whole lot better
for that uh
for their company um but some a lot of
times they don't want to pay the royalty
fees
and i think right now um unreal is doing
something really nice
if you listen if your game sells more
than a million then you can start paying
um obviously before then i don't think
it's gonna sell a million anyway so
you won't pay anything so i'm just
saying say
go to the unreal engine uh cut the crap
out you know stop trying to make
proprietary engines just to be difficult
for no damn reason
900p in this day and age you sh shame on
you sega
i got to say this the one thing that i
forgot about and that we haven't talked
about a lot
i think when we talk about you know we
laugh when we say things like secret
sauce and things like that
what um uh dlss 2.0 yes sir
is probably the biggest game changer
when it comes to these consoles
uh sort of being able to match come
close to pc performance like
performance because you can run these
games at actual super low resolutions
and
uh the the super sampling will
eventually get it to a point where
it's almost indiscernible from true 4k
so i you know obviously that's probably
not going to be the case at launch
but as we get a year in two years in
we're gonna start seeing these features
really affect games
and i guarantee you you're gonna see
games that you know the dev is gonna be
like
i'd rather give you this game at an
actual
at true 900 p and use dlss to upscale it
and you won't be able to tell the
difference but then i have all that
extra overhead for performance
no doubt yeah um christopher hart uh you
said something about
the game and the performance on the xbox
series x
worry about the performance on your
places
the weaker console are you implying
that people should be poking fun that he
need to get this part into his head
whatever performance issues that x the
series
x has not the s your playstation will
perform
worse so you don't have power
that those days are done okay it's
over now we're moving out
about taking your playstation and
ripping the wings off and leaving the
butt naked in the corner
oh my god you gotta get yourself before
i get to get this with you
yeah yeah i've done that again i just
think we haven't talked enough about
that
uh that super sample yeah that's going
to be huge for games on both consoles
across the board
facts facts we got some super chat we
gotta catch up with you
we have we have uh mike askew
if you're here with your job super chat
is avengers the milky way of gaming
oh my god they still with the candy bar
they're gonna stop that milky way
oh then we have black ronin also uh with
the five dollar super chat
next gen games should take better
advantage of series uh s uh
x because of the velocity alright there
we go velocity architecture as well
um all right so we caught up yeah we're
caught all right no doubt still look bad
like this oh we got one more thing hold
on
five dollar superstar from gaming for
today series s running yakuza at 900p
so who cares you really want more
performance to ask
for you people that buy an s are in the
tcl
dammit what table take gets that x in
pocket that's it baby no no
no more cheap talk oh lord get with me
oh oh no no
oh no no
[Laughter]
super chat had to do it will be the best
400
i spent today was that not removed
oh lord i'm checking i don't see the
notification oh yes he did
oh yes he did oh lord he did it yeah
uh 400 yeah yeah yeah uh the patreon
tier
uh soft what is that tear sir uh we're
gonna have to
the one hot chip challenge the what hot
chip challenge
oh how can you decide i don't want you
dying on stream
i got to do the one hot chip challenge
oh my god
i don't know now i gotta do i gotta i'm
gonna be on a live stream
for only the um whatchamacallit for only
the patreon and subscribers
and i got to do a one hot chip challenge
now let me tell you something we got we
got we got
400 and get ready
get rid of it yeah well he didn't do it
and now he came here
i got out
second let me tell you something just
like my nipple just like my nipple you
won't see my nipple you won't see me
choke and die
um unless you're a member of the patreon
or a member of the realm
so everybody is sitting there laughing
and keep keying it
right now because will me hill is trying
to kill me
all right is back
oh my god yes another tier shattered
we have all the joke tears oh my god oh
we have hopeless creek with the five
dollars in the chat milky way is in the
bushes
salute then we have near mental with the
five dollar super chat shout out to divo
will be hood
devo is back bringing fear in everyone
ridiculous
this is absolutely ridiculous we was my
friend
yo will me yo for now see i never say
anything i want a vr
i want to go i want to feel for them i
want to i'll give this to
this i'm sick and tired of you
you did you did half-life alex i need
restitution devin
because this right now i saw what i said
yo did y'all see what it happened what
happened to um
the the kiss move what when he did the
hot chip challenge
yes yeah he had to put the milk in his
mouth and he was just like
you know you got to drink a gallon you
have to have a drink of milk i don't
even drink milk
listen will like on god
you definitely okay he said okay
devo is back oh my god
that we have jonathan b with the five
dollars with that y'all gonna get enough
for testing will me with these patreons
exact boy chat right next to you
to have a big sack
[Laughter]
we put ridiculous tears for the realm
that doesn't know we put a lot of
ridiculous tears
kings that's a lot of rick let me tell
you something let me tell you something
i i put because they told me that i had
to participate
right you know one of those kids that
they say something
stupid make my dare something crazy
because nobody would do it
right so i put a thousand dollars a
tattoo
yep i will get the iron law's tattoo
first of all thought nobody ever was
gonna put a thousand dollars up because
we only had 15 people in the chat
facts
i was pretty sure that one of those 15
people was not didn't have a thousand
dollars just throw away
apparently uh wilmy was one of those 15
people
so
i saw what happened and i was like yo
put that for me nobody's ever gonna pay
400
for that well apparently wilmy hood just
got throw away money
listen dutch we wasn't mad at kick we
like come on
be realistic you'll never get it like
all of us have to do something you
that and then literally his drinks are
getting hit
with the only ones that got picked
this is really crap like because all of
these joints was like five dollars i
play a game with you five dollars
and i'm like what the hell with that i'm
not doing none of that i'm being bougie
oh my god wow let's get this super chat
[Laughter]
i'm going to be burning from the top and
the bottom that's like
some almond milk or something almond
milk almond milk salt
almond milk brother ice cream man i'm
good all right
all right well will mean you have
reached a tear we said it's all out of
love
we will uh we will set it up you know
your stitch you're off you come
at will me what's all the smoke my bad
king
it's gonna be hot who did that
[Laughter]
yo squirrely dan and and stitch just did
me dirty like yup
dudes y'all it was squirrely
i thought stitch was my man listen man
at this point yes
make a weave out of it yeah it's crazy
so look we will honor that we will set
it up obviously we know it'll be
exclusive to
uh members and youtube members and um
what you call it patreon subscribers
king will arrange the dates we'll get
that info of you like we did with the
tattoo and uh
you know order the chip and just let it
happen just let it happen on live
or tape god anyway let me get my balls
off for this 95
i'm literally sweating i'm sweating
right now i'm like yo
he's out there so look man look with the
900 p stuff
y'all oh my five dollar super chat mario
pablo will be hood is the true
big sack boy whoa y'all gotta put pause
at the end of that
man y'all y'all wanted frames over
resolution yeah y'all got it don't
complain now
y'all got 60 phrases i got it how y'all
want it man look at the end of the day
you know there there is a 1440 people
there is
just for the seriousness you know just
let y'all know it does exist
but of 30 phrases which i got to deal
with yeah but now all jokes aside
i do think it's the engine um i don't
want to i'm always pro
developer and i never want to be
disrespectful but like dutch said i find
it
hard to believe that you know that type
of game based on the fidelity of the
game
is more demanding than a gears 5
that is doing 120 frames you don't say
or the s
or you know um dirt and all these other
games that
just are way more demanding so listen at
the end of the day it's going to come
down to the skill of the developer
it's going to come down to these guys
getting more comfortable with the
hardware
and um that's it i really don't look at
it as an indictment on the s to be
honest with you
you know what i'm saying i do like the
fact that 60 is there though you know
what i'm saying and even with destiny i
like destiny they just announced 1080p
60.
again a game that in my opinion is way
more demanding
than yakuza turn-based you know no
disrespect because i'm looking i
love the fact that yakuza is there at
launch i think that is a tremendous look
japanese dev you know and it's time to
exclusive these type of games never come
to xbox
so salute to them but um sega please you
know get get get those tools get those
dev changes
it was the same for uh square enix
though with five fantasy 15 they had
their own in-house uh engine
and then for the remake they went back
to unreal yeah
yep absolutely so that that's where i'm
at so i'm gonna get the super chats then
we move on to the next one so yeah
we have uh the wise little gamer with
two that was retracted
retracted he retracted it because it had
to do with me
and then he realized that i don't have
anything that crazy
then we have duke jb welcome to the
realm
he's like yo kid gotta do the challenge
my god this is what people want this is
what we would we have to kill ourselves
let them die so we all caught up there
we're all caught up yeah all right man
so
this i believe king king is
okay up some news going on right now
about uh
jim ryan and city corps comments in
reference to playstation 5
and potentially a last console so
um i'll frame it because i believe it
was
jim brian he had a coke uh in believe it
was uh was it
financial times and he said the truth is
in regards to
uh consoles he says he doesn't know um
nobody doesn't know he said seven years
ago everybody was saying playstation 4
was going to be the last console it's
all going to be tablets and mobile
phones
and more recently it's been everything
will be in the cloud so nobody knows
and then um citigroup uh kodo uh
izawa a city group analyst he also feels
that the playstation 5 will be the last
console
and according to his hour games will
likely be played entirely online for the
playstation 6.
so this is you know a couple of people
with their speculation
as well as jim ryan you know maybe not
definitively saying it's not going to be
but
i will give it to you king this is your
topic you know where you at
even jim can see the writing on the wall
oh god
you ain't winning this fight the fight's
over fight so
because when phil dominus maximus is
really expensive
comes out and say oh this ain't our last
generation we got more
we're in the cooker you're cooking right
now
like and then jim dance moves comes out
and say this might be our last one
he said he doesn't know we don't know
what's gonna happen tomorrow
this market is
you're a fickle i'm done i can't commit
to none of you guys
like he looked through playstation dudes
in the eyes that
love it now because it might not be here
tomorrow oh my god
this is what you got out of this thing
this
is the last of us
[Laughter]
there's no double down he's giving you
absolutely no blanket
he just told you guys i i don't know man
you know um the way to market analysts
say that market analyst dude he's always
right
i think i'm gonna keep laying in his
clouds man you know
you know no more physical
that's savage you know it's just it's
it's sad to see
food is non-committal on anything
you know he has no ground to stand on
like
the only thing i hear from him is he we
will make quality games they've been
doing that before you
what do you stand for you stand for
generations
oh no you don't um you stand for making
consoles that everybody can believe in
no you don't um so what do you really
believe in i think this is concerning
when is
the generation didn't even start and
your man said this might be the last one
he did not say it's gonna be the last
one
he said he doesn't know he's not sure
that's
saying that i don't know if this is the
last one i mean
you want me to use his words i'm not
sure
we'll be around for you later
literally that doesn't that doesn't
instill
confidence in the fan base especially
when you're competitive well
you are competitive him because
microsoft don't see you as a
oh my god but when you view the big dog
you're like we aspire to be like them
and they're
they're working hard on research and
development in the new console but we're
not
like that scares the hell out of me that
here's the hell out of me
simply because you don't know
what effort you're going to put forward
to push for the next playstation 6.
you know um without the success of the
playstation 4
there wouldn't be a playstation 5. you
sold a 120 million 100
i said i say 130 million cop uh consoles
and that was the all due to the fan base
all right whatever you did in marketing
to get it to that number even if it's
not the hard call all the way
through they supported you so this is
how this is like a backhanded slap
before the console generation even
thought
you tell them yo um we are
in research and development that could
have been a blanket statement that
doesn't mean that
is we we're researching cloud or we're
researching hardware you just say we're
researching development for the next
console
so you don't need to know exactly what
the hell does that mean
but the fact that you say we don't know
what it's going gonna be
that doesn't give faith in the fan base
and i think that that's
i think his message is spot on because
he is a businessman he's a suit
running the company um with fans and
there's a difference between
him and phil if you look at phil phil is
a gamer
that's wearing a suit and half the time
he doesn't even want to wear a damn suit
so when you see jim
jim always his dress down is uh
taking off the tie and opening up the
top right
all right you're right be careful for
that dude
because that dude is always going to do
what corporate says because he can
always throw his tie on and run inside
the room
you know he can always change it up on
you at a moment's notice where
phil actually has like an xbox shirt on
and he's going inside the room like
yeah and you can know indications on
what games is going to be purchased like
limbo
like that off of his back because he is
a gamer
be careful his words ring true
and i don't i don't trust none of the
words that he say i think he's dancing
but he's dancing to his own
tune and he's going to do exactly what
in the best interest of that board
and if right now they take a splash on
this hardware right now and they
lose this generation you won't be around
for playstation 6.
so i'm going to get super chat then i'll
let dutch get his balls off and we got
jonathan b with the five dollar super
chat gym dance moves gave the answer
that you give your girl when you don't
want to do something
um i don't know let me check on a few
things
wow wow
what are you feeling about this comment
do you think king is on something or do
you think this is an exaggeration
no i don't think it's an exaggeration i
don't i don't but
they've tried they've tried to push
these kind of questions to xbox before
and they've
kind of went around it and said listen
cloud is an addition
to physical consoles
cloud's never going to be on top of
physical consoles because it's
unless the infrastructure changes
dramatically you're not going to be able
to do
4k 120 hertz games over the cloud
no it's we don't have the infrastructure
for that playstation with your hand
they're just going oh yeah when
cloud gaming is a thing it might or
might not be the way we go
going forward we might or might not have
a console going forward
but unless they step the game up and get
an infrastructure in place
shopish that's not going to happen fair
enough
microsoft have azure microsoft is azure
mm-hmm
does the playstation have parts within
azure
they don't have that they don't have the
infrastructure in place themselves
to be able to just go playstation five
cloud right it's it's not that quick
it's took it's the the length of time
microsoft has taken for it
to get azure so the stature it is now
is exactly why even even even cloud
cloud game and beta is brilliant but you
can tell it's still
in its infancy yes there's a lot that
needs and out first
you can't just jump from physical
console to cloud gaming in five years
that's not won't happen right no i think
it's
they just don't know what direction they
want to go in i don't understand i think
they don't know where the
problem is is xbox have spoken openly
about this over
every previous generations have said
what we need to do is not see
what is popular now but what what is
also going to be
valid the big thing in five six seven
years time
sony at the moment that they probably do
an r d for the
for the next console or next place to
play and don't understand where that
market will be going and just
assume because cloud is up and coming
that cloud is the thing
cloud is going to be the only place you
play and i don't think that's going to
be the case i think you will always need
physical media to play that off
now fair enough man so let's get uh
solved man
what you got uh super chat and then you
yeah we have the wise old gamer with the
five dollar super chat gamers
hey playstation want to go out next gen
playstation uh
i don't know i'm washing my hair that
night
y'all messy man i would really like to
know
where some of these analysts get their
expertise from what
what what cracker jack box are you
opening
that because i'm like these guys are
just
morons like themselves
is there a possibility that could be
that everybody could be gaming on like
dutch was saying everybody could be
gaming solely online and in the cloud
yeah like in 20 25 years playstation 5
generation lasts
25 years then man maybe it's impossible
that this is their last console like it
was
yo that that article was such idiot it
was idiot soup
who wrote this like
they wrote it for king they wrote it for
king i said they didn't grab that and
put that in the chat
if you saw this if you saw this i was on
m4g yesterday i know i wasn't crazy
and one analyst predicted that the
playstation 5 could sell
500 million so i
asked you where the hell did you get
where did you get your degree from
like because i will blow you the bushes
if you give me advice like that like
yeah bro
straight bushes continue like this this
whole idea that cloud is going
to be the thing and anything
shorter than you know close to three
decades from now
is is a fool's game no
no no in the
come on you know you're coming out with
a six you know you're up so if you get
the clocks clean
in this round right here you think they
come out i mean if they
get they get smoked like a pack of
cigarettes
this is one thing we always have to
remember right when you talk about they
see this
and king is right because as
popular and as as as as
popular as the playstation name is in
gaming right as it's the big name in
gaming
when you think about their they're
attached to sony
right and they are the biggest thing in
sony right now nobody's thinking about
sony's tvs nobody's thinking about
sony's other consumer products it's
playstation it is the big thing
if the rest of sony falls to the point
where that cannot uh
kind of buoy the playstation the
playstation can't buoy the rest of sony
you know a real possibility exists the
playstation as part of sony
could go away that's that's just a
reality of
that company so um do i think the
playstation
goes away no i think they do everything
in their power to sell it to somebody
else
if if sony can't sustain playstation
anymore
on playstation on playstation you're
right
um but yeah that that is a real thing
that can happen
obviously because we saw that with the
if the playstation 4 were not the
runaway success
that it that it is and they came into
this generation stumbling like they did
in the ps2 generation
we might be having a totally different
car that's true and and i would agree
they they
won the generation that needed to be won
like that let this last generation was
very critical
because coming into with that mindshare
now into this generation uh agree let me
let me give about unless we got some
each other and get my eyes off no we are
good on super
cool no no actually no we have the gamer
hold on we have
we have jd game with the five dollar
switch out salute to the iron lords the
gym is dancing dancing dance dancing
dancing
[Laughter]
the fact that he did not give a clear
answer
it was baffling to me like it's like
really you this
this is not this is not truth like all
right
let me yeah y'all being extra today look
let me jump in
you know damn well he cannot say
this yet when the five is about to drop
you you're not trying to cut that
money no no i feel you but the fact that
you don't know listen
as a business oh you know in the middle
of this like
you know full well cloud is not going to
be at the point in five or six years
where everything's going to be in the
cloud it's just not there so just
you know at least correct the idiot
that's asking you the dumb question
and you know you just didn't make
anything brother corporate speak 101
you know how the game is played we
cannot
tell these guys that are about to buy
our new
system just like we couldn't tell it was
coming playstation 4 to the last minute
as far as the games you can't tell them
because you want them
invested we got to get some of this
money
but think about it think about it who's
who in their right mind is going to be
like oh he's talked about a playstation
six that could come out in seven years
i'm going to wait
but it's just it's just pr 101
you know what i'm saying yeah you're
trying to sell the new giant you can't
talk about that you know what it is this
is where we get used to microsoft's
transparency
and sometimes microsoft is trans true
transparent for their own good
because remember when the scorpio was
being developed they was like oh yeah we
working on the new joint right there
like they they
tell you right off rip and we are so
used to that level of transmission
it doesn't but at the end of the day you
know say it like some
casuals shout out to fuzzy like in the
chat
some casuals get it like oh they're
making another one so i might as well
wait for the next one
because decades you know some casuals if
they
hear certain things you know they want
to know that their purchase is the
definitive purchase and
you know that's why he got to create the
smoking to the frugal gamer
to you frugal gamers out there getting
pinching
i mean i love i love what you assess out
of
i love what you gather out of these
quotes
it's amazing to me
look man he's he is dancing he's dancing
there's no question this is corporate
marketing dancing
one-on-one listen we all know right now
the infrastructure for stuff is still
being built we're still countries are
still
you know we just i just got 5g just now
you know and it's still not even
always up to stuff you know look at the
end of the day
you know i will agree with them we don't
know how the industry is going to go
you know what i'm saying but i do agree
with you solve
even with this generation we don't damn
well and still ain't ready to be at all
online
you know saying kind of thing we know
that you know saying it's just corporate
stuff
and listen i feel king king is not about
the dancing
you know what i'm saying king is about
like he he's with his man phil dominus
maximus aurelius you know what i'm
saying and dom you know he's got the
confidence xbox has that confidence
where they're just going to tell you
but we got to understand in corporate
america that's rare
most companies ain't telling you all
that stuff you know what i'm saying so
that's i think we're a little spoiled by
yeah microsoft
lied here microsoft for a long time has
tried not to treat their consumers like
idiots
and like stations still kind of does
that like and and a lot of it comes down
to positioning right
when you're in the lead you know what
i'm saying you could be
a little bit more mysterious you don't
have to you hot
girl you could tell somebody i don't
know if you're going to go out there
exactly
but but the average looking to uglier
guy
he got to go extra he gotta bring the
candy he gotta bring the
you know what i'm saying like it's like
i'm available tuesday
exactly i'll drive you home i'll tell
your parents
like that that's microsoft right now
because that's the positioning here
dude it's over oh my god tell you
something see because this is what i
they wanted me to get away from they
didn't want to walk away from this they
didn't want me to finish this up
i'm going to tighten it up it's over the
fight is over
all right you're already starting the
deficit and it's only going to get worse
so i don't care how many of you
playstation dudes out there talking
about i'm gonna buy the five i'm gonna
support you only buying one
it's gonna get to the point right now
when it's gonna be overwhelming you see
it right now
like we lost this generation i can admit
it
it's oh we lost it does jim dance move
ryan look like phil
dominus maximus of you no i don't think
uh uh jim dance moves to fight
i don't think he got that bite down in
that grit
i think when it gets to kicking he's
gonna say cloud is on
why are you sounding like ali right now
you sound like ali
i'm telling you right now when the worst
must have happened
your playstation gonna poof and turn
into the cloud
disrespect hold on lord shut up we got
loads of gaming in the building let me
shout out lords and gaming shout out to
gene
you know what i'm saying scrubbing them
off gene he said king might be on to
something what
he said king about the order something
about the playstation 5 not being out
this year
i am 39 whoppers deep since and no
playstation
what if microsoft's next big purchase is
playstation oh lord
we will have a lot of people committing
suicide in the chat
that's what's going to happen if that
happens shout out to jean he said he's
kidding okay okay he's going to make
sure gene
he knows the damn world true
sony as an insurance company is one
natural disaster in japan and samsung
kicking their butt in consumer
electronics
some more away from complete collapse
yeah
there are factors that affect sony that
when you're a playstation fan you don't
necessarily
think about um but they're intrinsically
tied to playstation in a way that is
dangerous for playstation
um then we have smitty smith with the
five dollar super chat man is crazy when
sony's transparency
needs transparency that was funny
all good we are good we're caught up all
right cool let's do a quick bonus round
because these are some topics that the
realm asked us they died for us to talk
about
we'll make this super quick just a
little bonus round quick fire so the
first thing will be me which will be uh
what games are you booting up on your
next gen console
first and why so let's start up with
dutch as far as
the playstation 5 the series x what's
the first game for each that you are
booting up sir
yeah and that leads onset for series x
does it i think you know what game i'm
putting up first
we go all viking with it all vegan
that's valhalla
no doubt no doubt what about
god foreign
it makes sense with you too it makes
sense
lord solve quick hitter what you doing
man both systems deck j
consoles what's the first game for each
man
maybe yeah man listen you resolve this
always there for me at the launch of a
generation man
as much as i love playing rise and stuff
like that um
at the start of this generation i i i
finished
uh black flag before any one of those
other games so
and ubisoft's always there um i'm going
to be excited to put on watch dogs as
well
right i want to see that um and and for
a smaller game the falconer so
we don't have that yet but i want to
keep the falconer for those of you um
og xbox guys who played god why can't i
remember the
the shooting flying game from og xbox
now that i don't know oh
crimson whatever crimson sky yeah
crimson skies uh the falconer looks
absolutely fantastic and beautiful so i
want to see
that and then playstation what you're
doing it's gotta be mild it's got to be
mine
gotta be miles like closely followed by
obviously demon souls i wanna see demons
and then after that yeah i might laugh
could be big sack big sack let's get it
you know what i want to see again
it reminds me of super mario 3d world
right and if platforming is that good
then it deserves a look if it's floaty
like past
all right so we got that cake i'm very
curious well next-gen consoles both
series x and playstation 5
what are the first games you are
launching
oh being that two of my games got by
default
in the stomach you know cyberpunk the
19th kicked in the stomach
um destiny so
um those two games i was gonna launch um
so it's gonna have to be but valhalla by
default
make it holla yeah on the x axis
people don't know how much i really like
spider-man so
i don't care i'm i wouldn't even get
that system if it wasn't on
there um the fact that it is there
i'm going to get it and that's the only
reason why and i probably won't play
nothing on that playstation until next
year sometimes
i'm curious uh what's the second game
you're touching a playstation
some connection oh that so it's balanced
and that's it i'm just buying miles i'm
not buying nothing else
damn everything there is trash like
trash i don't play demon souls
it's trash and i'm definitely not
playing god for why would i play a
bootleg destiny
purchase that right there with the three
guys on screen
in the bushes
they got to give me that game for free
oh my god you know what it is
know what i play day's gone oh my god
seven days yeah all right fair enough do
actually finish the game gameplay the
playlist yeah wow i stopped playing it
on my playstation once they said 60
frames
i said wait i would just boot that up
over there
and they confirmed your same date is
going so that's what's up i don't know
about all that live
he's talking about that we don't know
because the day it released the devil
said it
you're gonna see it on twitter like
you're gonna be in the store
and you're gonna be picking it up and
they're gonna be like my bad what
you know the destiny was a shot you know
to the stomach for me because obviously
when people were
sad about halo being delayed i was like
i'm good i was like i got destiny
people like they ain't got no perfect i
don't care i got destiny
like like i really didn't care all that
noise people would talk about it didn't
matter because
i was so hyped for series x 60 frames
and then budget broke his heart yeah
oh song hit me he's like yeah you didn't
hear
i'm like hey what he's like yeah
december 8th that's when you getting
your update
i said oh man then i had to go on the
last word
he bounces teasing me so you're coming
back to pc high for another month right
i was like oh man so yo put the crest up
real quick then i'll finish up
we have the living flame welcome to oh
the little place is
no doubt no doubt that we have emmanuel
a1 with the three dollar super chat king
david ain't never lie
demon souls is trash wow
that getting gonna sell even though i'm
not a dog
so look you know so that was that so now
it came down to
you know um what was left so i i am a
yakuza guy you know i'm saying so i do
want to see that
but i'm a surprise y'all a game no one's
talking about
snacks no
but when it comes down to it
bright memory oh one point
memory 1.0 yo shout out to that dude
he's a single developer on the game
but was it fyqd um that game on pc which
i've never played
it supports it's 4k 60 or they ran it
with a 2080 ti
and it was 4k 60 with ray tracing so i'm
not going to ask for the ray tracing off
rip
but 4k 60 i feel it's a great graphical
showcase type of game
and i want to get into i've heard good
things about it yes i heard it short
it's the first episode we know infinite
because i don't care what nobody say
people who hate on that third party
showcase my xbox bright memory
infinite looked crazy to me yeah you
know what i'm saying
that joint so i want to see the origin
like where it started at
so bright memory i'm i'm a rock with
that i'll throw on um yakuza just
because i love yakuza just to see what
they doing
gears tactics of course and then i got
to flex on them king
people could say what they want about
dirk and yo
therefore they got a 4k 120 mode fan
i'm in i got to see what that my cx
could do
dutch listen i got to see what my cx
could do because
you know like king was saying some some
media outlets
weren't showcasing it at the highest
fidelity so yeah my team
my tv can do it
so i'm gonna be i'm gonna see what dirk
really could do i wanna
plus the real real i've never played a
120 game so it's a it's a perfect uh
demo for hdmi 2.1
and i'm in and plus like i said get
attacks with the join so for playstation
i'm going to surprise y'all like listen
for you
if they got demos that day just play the
demo bro
nobody got no 120 frames demo
just ain't got no 120 frame bruh i'm
getting that dirt sir we
in there
you just put on you never get past the
start menu yo
check it out yo shout out to dealer
he's got a good video out on it shout
out to digital foundry who really broke
it down
you know what i'm saying it looked good
when i was watching the 4k version on
youtube
i was like i don't know what people talk
about the the the terrain the mud all
that joining like fire playing out run
everything listen shout out to will me
yes i'm dirt son they sleeping on dirt
anyway please send your fight of course
you know what i'm saying miles but i
think i'm with
i think it was dutch man god fall first
man
i think i might i might get that that
golf on is something
you know what is i was hot and cold with
it but then when i saw the narrative
trailer
that kind of got me if if they got a
story like that all throughout
just look at king sucking this thing i'm
definitely in there man so yeah
i'm not listening to nothing you're
saying that's hot
gay fodder destruction you don't hear
nobody talk about destruction
the derby part four whatever the hell
that thing is
doing black flips into the arena like
nobody from the game nobody talk about
that but again
one of those little uh bargain bin games
you'll throw that in what we got for
lunch those
guys what are those for you you don't
listen man i got to see what the swords
do
anyway so that's that and last question
that the rob want us to ask again quick
fire real quick
uh phil uh seemingly confirming
you know what i'm saying as far as the
xenomax studios acquisition had an
interview with steven to tell her for
kataku so i don't know if you guys
caught that but um
dutch man what do you think uh do you
think this is official now
that these games will be exclusive to
playstation
i mean xbox subscribe
quite the opposite yeah it's always
official we just can't see it until the
wait until the uh the pens dry mm-hmm
um but no the word and it was actually
following the part where we asked him
yes the wording was a little bit more in
depth
after that yes um there was an old quote
that
he was uh he was referenced again um
stating
um what about xbox one first party games
going to other platforms in the future
is it still a case of um kind of that
won't happen
following um ori 2 and he simply stated
ori 2 was always
a second party and the it's actually
been published by take two on
the switch yes that was by the
developer's request it isn't the first
party so we
accepted that request but all first
party unless other platforms are willing
to have xbox live ecosystems on their
platform
then it is not going to be on that
platform so basically duchy's implying
if you want it
you put game pass on yourself
if you want it there's one way to do it
yeah let's get this he wants
he wants xbox live on there he wants
xbox achievements on there he wants
getting past
and if he can't have those three things
on a platform then it's not going to
that platform
so basically just to confirm that i
botched the framing which was
steve steven asked him is it possible to
recoup a 7.5 billion investment if you
don't sell elder scrolls
on the playstation and phil's answer was
yes
we don't need to recoup basically and
then he kind of
doubled down he said look um the deal
was not he said that the intention of
the deal was not to take games away from
another player base like that
knowing that nowhere in the
documentation that we put together was
how do we keep other players from
playing these games
but he says i'll also say in the model
i'm just answering directly to the
question that you had
when i think about where people are
going to be playing and the number of
devices that we had
and we have xcloud pc game pass and our
console base
i don't have to go ship those games on
any other platform
other than the platforms that we support
in order to kind of make that deal work
for us
so in my opinion dutch i agree with you
that is pretty much plain as day you
know what i'm saying
however you know what i'm saying i do
agree that the reason why people like
why wasn't he just saying it outright
like you said dutch i think you said it
good the ink is still
dry and they have to wait for all things
i think february is when it actually
gets
done up so i'm gonna go through the
official legalities of being signed off
by all the finance i mean 7.5 billion is
a lot of money that has to be
cross-referenced
absolutely it's it's not just going to
the shop and buying a game
[Laughter]
not that simple so sovereign king
yeah i mean listen we when we first
talked about this
we said it there's no no chance in hell
this is happening you don't spend seven
five
7.5 billion to the to put it on your
the opposing platform as i we've talked
a lot over over the past couple of years
about how do you devalue
your properties you want to devalue
those properties you put them on on
playstation because what happens is at
that point you look weak
you look like you you look like you you
made a mistake and you spent too much
money and you you
don't know how to you look weak there's
no way in hell you spend that much money
not to not to improve game pass which is
what you're trying to do the game
the the bottom line the end game for
them is game pass it's just
and you need to bring people there so
there's it was always going to be the
case
i understand the things that the two
things you guys said specifically are
exactly on the money the ink is still
drying right so you never know something
could happen but i
i doubt that'll happen but then cause
still drives you can't say anything
definitively
and and secondly i think phil he knows
how bad it sounds just to come out and
be like you're not getting it yeah i'm
not getting this
phil has always been phil has always
been very diplomatic he's
he's never been that dude to come out
and say something that like
in that way right he'll say it but not
not he won't you know smack your face
with it
so um this is just a full way of
answering the question
but i think you know let's put this to
bed once and for all
those games are not coming period
yeah fair enough lord king okay so y'all
know
k and pill right the show and when they
have obama and they have the angry dude
behind obama talking all right so they
asked fill the question and i'm
standing behind phil with my own
and he said you know uh you know at this
point in time blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah
and i say oh you got a playstation don't
you
you want those games don't you well you
can't get those games
you have to buy x if you're not in the
xbox ecosystem go get an android phone
you want those games you're gonna have
to step your game up
you wanna play with us you're gonna have
to play with us that's what he said
right so
we're not playing with you we don't
expect money
to be putting stuff over there so if you
like
my playstation system you're gonna have
to put
so all you playstation dudes hoping and
praying every day
is this really true is this really
happening yes
this is the world that we are living now
this is post covert it's over
i don't like your phone right there so
so
make sure when you go to the store with
your mask
you're going to go buy your xbox because
you need an xbox now
it's not that you want an xbox you need
it
so i don't care which size you get if
you go get the s
or soda x i don't care how you do it
just go get it done
it's over it's awful thank you thank you
from phil spencer
angry phil the angry phil dominance's
translator
thank you for your contribution
for this situation how do we we have
clarity thanks to you
so if you want to get a suggestion okay
we got sweetie with five dollar super
chat microsoft to sony and my
uh heath ledger dark knight voice it's
not about the money
it's about sending a message
[Laughter]
yo that was good song that was good uh
we did that for you book of acts
people don't understand microsoft only
needs to make more interest back on that
7.5 billion investment
than what they would have gotten in a
bank game pass will do it
absolutely i think you know what another
thing that people people assume like
that they have to make this back in a
couple of months like it's like they
break like they money ain't long like
we're talking about microsoft pockets
did they sell
they tell you so hey sony did you make
back that 250 million that you put in
that thing
did you get your money back sony
super chats on fire so you got to get
them here we got uh
m kai with the 5 super chat microsoft's
new slogan xbox has no games now
xbox has your game yo yo
that's all body karate
we got jd gamer with the five dollar
super chat be whole field dominance
maximus aurelius is not done with your
playstation
fan just wait till the next acquisition
is announced and watch them cry
oh my god oh so you all caught up
yeah we're good we're good yeah the same
thing we already know what this we
talked about it when the announcement
happened
you know how we feel you know what's
funny no one's even talking about some
little signs that we're seeing wasn't
soft they had like a um
i'm going to say like a almost like a
wolfenstein collection
yeah so the collection apparently and i
may be wrong about this initially this
this collection of different bethesda
games
or from what i thought they were coming
to playstation 4
right and definitely not playstation 5.
right
i think that changed and it's not coming
to playstation platforms at all i still
may be wrong about that
i'm just yeah the fact that those
you know those are those are games that
are already on that those platforms
right
so this you would think that there is no
reason to not put them there because
they're already there in a different
form
right but these are going to be these
are going to be sort of uh upgraded and
whatnot for next year and is that any
other
so it's going to come in as a new skew
right so
if if the answer to that is no
playstation platform is not getting it
right
that should tell you that should tell
you immediately look we're not willing
to give you
these remasters of these old games right
you're definitely not getting a new
stuff yeah because i just find it very
interesting the esrb conveniently
missing the playstation 5 versions of
these joints i mean some things are not
coincidence guys we got to pay attention
look you know i say like king said i
mean look when
fanboys the whole gen are bullying
saying you got no games dudes got tired
of it they got the street sweeper
like they got the street sweet but they
they they they backed them down
it's like okay this is what it is now we
buying the block so
can't get mad you know what i'm saying
this is this is how it is you know i i
love the
the the aggressiveness of the move we
all felt that was the realiest move by
phil
and you know to me it's just what dutch
said the ink ain't dry yet so we ain't
gonna make
1 000 definitive but we
leaning y'all in that direction now so
get ready
you know what i'm saying before you get
surprised when you see a star field or
elder scrolls or a fallout and they
don't have
your favorite logo on the bottom so
[Laughter]
that's lord bethesda right there that's
what it says i'm very happy to see you
glad to have you in the family yes man
salute salute and uh you know todd did
bend the knee hank i know you hate this
that's right
both knees knees balls down to fail
it was filled down this did that i know
that was oh god point of contention back
in the day with
king but i salute to my boy it's over
excellent but look we got you too
we got you it's a beautiful day it's a
real thing so just getting you guys know
what's up let's get this poll let's get
up out of here oh actually another super
chat right
bernard miller with the two dollars
which had the best new buy would be
capcom
thoughts yes i think king mumbled that
earlier
listen bernard and you sound like
somebody i know bernard i swear
miller sounds like somebody i know
anyway um
yeah i posted that i posted something
that somebody sent me and i just had to
let it out i said can i say that can i
let it out he's like
ahead so i let it out and it's the
capcom building
in japan so yeah hey that would be a
great look if they can pull it off
we shall see let's get this poll now
with the playstation 5 ui
reveal which feature has you most
excited about the interface
a 4k hdr superior
dashboard
[Music]
you gotta have fun with these phones man
dashboard is hot ssd
loading speeds and clean interface c
ps5 snap feature with tips and friend
lists
or d i don't care this system's still
getting delayed until attention who
foundry
get their hands on it you know let's
stand up guys let's get in
there i got to see if cakes allegiance
again shout out to all the people those
are the questions these are as these
will go up later on today
shout out to lord wondering dutch of the
midweek
mix-up podcast the gaming viking himself
absolute pleasure in the realm where can
the fine people find you what you got
going on sir
certainly certainly thank you very much
for having us absolutely honored to be
on and uh again love to do it again
there and
get your back on the show in the future
yes that was good fun good fun
um you can find me on twitter
wanderingdutch on
wanderingdutch on youtube wandering
dutch
pretty much all the same um and again on
wednesday
we have will me and the gang joining us
you got the wow you got the wild boys
that's going to be fun that's going to
be a funny show so you guys you got will
me and [ __ ] what you got who you got
will meet husk fork italian oh you got
the squad
oh he's about to go down make sure you
get um next time
um what's his face um so he could bring
his tcl
obama yeah obama he did yes
oh his favorite bring bomber with the
team
everybody's screaming everybody's saying
we gotta start the shaving we gotta
start the fun now shout out to shout out
to mama good dude we
always joking or that's he actually
think about getting his own leg but yeah
salute brother
it has been absolutely a pleasure to
have you man you're killing it right
there love your story love the
background
and like i said just supporting good
dudes in the community positive energy
love your crew man salute your crew
everybody in the team
good podcast check them out man wonder
dutch give up give out the information
you can find certainly yeah certainly so
again wednesdays
as uh with our regular panels so it's
myself as a host wondering dutch then
you have
forza irwin pacquiao or 7-0
chambollon roya and archimedes boxing
burger as a main panel
i like that i'm alone
[Music]
yo shout out to y'all beat yo i like
y'all y'all intro beat that beat y'all
gets it started getting popped that's
what's up
no doubt yeah every wednesday is it uh
8pm gmt
or 3 p.m est nice training catch
nice a little man again support the
dutch out here
doing it big was fun to do this lord
attic did hit me
up so unfortunately he wasn't in the
bushes completely he had lost they lost
power in his area
phone everything's down so he's he's
upset so shout out to attic he will
hopefully be
in here next minute
[Laughter]
he was on that wi-fi like yo
my phone ain't working what happened why
are we in the dark
shout out to attic man yo salute to my
bro he will be back hopefully next week
there's some power but lord solve what's
going on sir where can i find people
find you
know that first off shout out to dutch
man i i love
guys that come in here with the old pc
experience
just because we i remember those horror
days like
when you crack open the pt it's nothing
like it is now like now it's literally
like putting together legos like
it's like a modular thing you just go
back then
it was a horror show when you open up a
pc and you're like all right where's the
graphics card where's the sound card
geforce oh my goodness who do vfx
so man it's fantastic to hear your story
and to see how you how you help the
community is absolutely fantastic so
thank you for coming through
um for me i do not have to work today
since i they put me in the bushes
earlier this morning so i i'm actually
going
to sleep for a little while and then i'm
going to go do some stuff with my wife
and know that that is absolute salute oh
and
i'm sorry i forgot to say this earlier
on big shout out to the tampa bay rays
because you know i always got to go with
the team that takes out my yank so i got
to go with them
but especially big shout out for taking
out those cheating [ __ ]
damn there's a lot of yankee love going
on right now all right i'll see you i'll
see you
anyway lord king we're going to five
people fights what you got going on sir
well first
phil spencer phil domino's really
expensive official
yo you know before that yo how hot a
commercial would it be
if like phil's really doing that and
instead of the teleprompter like king's
behind phil
and he say what phil really want to say
that that would be lit like he'd think
like this and i'd just be talking that'd
be crazy you're aaron get on that
um marketing we need to do that
shout out to my man wandering dutch that
midweek
mix-up boy there joey
you have a very diverse cast uh
you guys are definitely mixed well i
love that stuff
you know i love the organicness of it so
if any of y'all didn't get a chance to
check it out go follow
uh dutch make sure that you go uh follow
uh the podcast the midweek mix up it is
it is fun as hell yeah i had such a
great time we it went so crazy that we
were just like okay we got to stop the
show yeah
oh you can catch me this week uh with
kos
iron man old school shell head um i'm
going to be talking about i'm going to
probably find the hulk
of a book where he rips his watchman
caller off the chair off his chest
i'm old i am manhattan i don't really
like the new school i am at suits
uh that much is it crap to me um
but i like uh you know the old school
repulsors i like i like how he was
fitting it was form fit it was great
it worked for me uh let me tell you the
story about that
and why i got this statue this
masterpiece and then
then we can go on to um combat talk was
supposed to be back this week but
we definitely have another combat talk
cause uh
fighting is uh making a huge comeback
and i gotta respect dana white for
showing
every sport yeah away yeah
island yes he's he's a visionary uh that
doesn't get enough credit
and if he wasn't fighting as hard as he
possibly could to get the ufc
to a bubble to show the world how it
could be done we wouldn't got basketball
um football is trying it in their way
and i think that they're failing because
they're not
exactly uh utilizing how he has it done
a campus-style environment on an island
where everybody's being tested around
the clock
you know and keeping it clean because we
haven't heard anything
out of the ufc dana white for getting us
uh
back to sports normalcy well whatever we
got sports now
uh so that's definitely what's up so
we're gonna have combat talk there
listen i want you guys to go to the
teespring store as you see
yeah baby let's get it
it's like the king snuggie yes sir the
link is pinned to the chat y'all
right there get that get that swag the
ilp swag
go check that out we got the little
covered mask we got the mat yo
the neck gate a little crazy we look
like straight bandits
[Music]
king david otw when i'm out here laying
the smackdown on these sony ponies
having mad fun with people listen if
y'all keep it respectful i won't block
you
which is really funny and i definitely
will repost your joint
oh you can catch me at dolph castle x on
friday it's at 9 00 pm
know it's crazy you know you can catch a
couple of millionaires and they're
talking about statues
that you know we're struggling to buy so
it's actually really funny stuff shout
out to will be he said teespring's name
is accurate but
buy something in the fall you may see it
in the spring
that was fire it was fire man yo get
that super chat
we got vogel's creek with the five
dollar super chat great show and
hopefully my braves beat the dodgers
tonight to meet the rays yeah absolutely
braves deserve it to go dodgers in the
bushes did you see
how many people they let into that damn
stadium yeah that's crazy oh
hell no everybody got covered yeah oh my
god
what are y'all doing what about it
actually
forte with the exclusive heads up looks
like retailers are holding stock for
series x for day one bye
most likely no more prior okay good
looking good looking forte appreciate it
i called this last week actually of uh
uk retailers have already said that
discreetly
phil wants you to be able to walk in the
storm purchase i'm telling you this
playstation thing is dead
because you're going to walk in the
store you're going to be like yo can i
get a playstation and like nah man we
don't know whenever we're gonna get that
we don't even know when it's gonna
launch
or what else you got wow look at this
store it looks so beautiful what is this
xbox that's a big screen what do you
think
this 4k60 what is that dirt what's that
dirt
[Laughter]
that's 120 that's 120 hertz i can't
get it anyway shout out to them
i am not that dude in the store
listen man but shout out to dizzy
greyburg knows the allocation look
everybody salute to the chat man please
like and subscribe again follow water
and dutch follow the midweek mix up
podcast salute them brothers out there
doing it
well we got some more fun stuff in the
realm lined up for you guys man
appreciate the support
if anybody got anything else we up out
of here everybody enjoy
your weekend out of here wait wait wait
wait wait wait
oh my god i just wanted to stay there
hi this is lord sovereign from the iron
lord podcast as you guys may recall
a few months back king david otw
announced an amazing giveaway for the
xbox series x
well i'm proud to announce that the iron
lords podcast will once again be giving
away another console
at the end of this year and that console
will be a playstation
5. you heard correctly so
how do you get in on this amazing
giveaway let me explain
if you're already a member of the realm
you're good to go if you support us
either on patreon
or youtube you already have a ballot to
win this
amazing console and if you support us on
both platforms
you have two ballots to win this amazing
console as you also have two ballots to
win an xbox series x
so if you're not a member of the realm
what are you waiting for head on over to
patreon.com
go to the ironlord's podcast patreon
page become a member of the realm
to get your chance to win a playstation
5.
you can also join us on youtube iron
lord podcast
become a member of the realm and you
will also have a ballot to win
a playstation 5 console and if you want
to support us on both
platforms you'll have two ballots for
each system
to win either a playstation 5 console or
of course as king david said
and xbox series x this is an amazing
opportunity
that the iron lords podcast are so happy
to bring to our community because you
guys give so much back to us
so again if you're not a member of the
realm yet what are you waiting for
go out join the realm on either patreon
or youtube and until next time i'll see
you at the